Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Ich merke nichts mehr in meinem Hintern.
Monatlicher IQ Boost. So muss das sein.
Pogu.
Exzellent.
War ein bisschen was entspannenderes als Musik.
Zack.
Top 100 Mario Song.
Das ist...
Top 50? Top 100?
Was hatten wir immer?
Roll.
Ich glaube, es ist top 200.
Wir haben sogar top 200!
Na, ob da Nintendo mit einverstanden ist?
Ich denke, ja nicht.
Aber Nintendo, ich meine,
Nintendo ist eigentlich mit nichts einverstanden.
Wie viele Tabs?
Ja.
Da?
Und sicherlich in der VMA noch ein paar.
Ich meine,
ich meine,
ernsthaft guck mal.
Ich hab
64GB RAM.
Das da unten ist das
neues Feature
Windows 11.
Ich hab 64GB RAM.
Irgendwo muss der Speicherplatz ja hin.
Können wir heute backseaten?
Ja, ich weiß bloß auch gar nicht, was wir machen.
Was haben wir denn heute, Leute?
Was haltet ihr denn davon?
Wir könnten uns mal wieder ein paar aktuelle
Stellenanzeigen angucken.
Was da so dabei, ob da irgendwas
bescheuertes dabei ist.
Ja, wir können mal so auf den
üblichen Seiten gucken.
Was da gerade wieder
gesucht wird an
dev bis sec win
bis obs
Jobwechsel
Ne
Hab ich erst
Wo haben wir denn da immer geguckt?
Also ich, ich, ich
Admin Rockstar
Geht schon gut los
So, das ist immer so eine ganz gute
Best-Off-Seite
Stepstone ist ganz gut
an Jobs
Ja, LinkedIn würde ich auch, aber bin ich nicht
eingeloggt, kann ich mich auch nicht einloggen, weil ich
Passwort nicht mal weiß
Also keine Ahnung
Leute, Leute, lass uns mal kurz ein bisschen was
entspannteres suchen
Komm wir machen noch ein bisschen
Wupp Wupp Wupp an, ist mir eigentlich egal
Hauptsache, Hauptsache gechillt
Wupp Wupp Wupp Wupp
Dann Streamtitel ändern
Ja, gleich
Können wir machen, ja, ich ändere
Ja, richtig, richtig
Das geht exklusiv, Leute
Nur hier
könnt ihr Twitch Prime benutzen
Irgendwo anders geht das nicht, nur hier
Sollte man, vielleicht dürfte das mal erwähnen
World Exclusive
Was machen wir denn für einen Titel
für den Stream?
Stellenanzeigen, Review
Irgend so ein blödes Emoji dahinter, also
Perfekt
So
Magst du ans Trinken?
Tatsächlich. Sollte ich machen, ja
Du hast heute eine neue
Stelle unterschrieben, als was?
Ja
Progu Subscription
Übrigens euch fällt vielleicht auf
Vielleicht
Wundert ihr euch
Wie ich es hingekriegt habe, dass der Chat
wieder funktioniert
Was meint ihr? Was habe ich gemacht?
Dass der Chat wieder funktioniert
Ansonsten war ja immer das Problem, dass es
Kann ich euch zeigen, wenn ich hier
Inkognito aufmache
Dann
Kam immer so ein Overlay
Dann kam so ein Overlay
Eingeloggt. Richtig
Das Banalste überhaupt
Ich hab mich eingeloggt
Aber
Nicht mit meinem normalen Wublos-Account
Mit irgendeinem Fake-Account
Ich habe irgendein Fake-Account erstellt
Schnell E-Mail-Adresse weitergeleitet
Von einem meiner 30.000 Bromains
Und
Ja, Fake-Account erstellt
Wisst ihr was ich auch mal ausprobieren wollte?
Kurz den Account banden
Du weißt doch gar nicht welches es ist
Wisst ihr was ich auch mal ausprobieren wollte?
Schon eine Weile
Wie gut ist eigentlich
Die kostenlose VM
In der Oracle Cloud
Hatten wir da schon mal ausprobiert?
Hatte ich mich da schon mal angemeldet?
Bei Oracle Cloud anmelden
Auch bestimmt Kreditkarte
Telefonnummer
Und ganzes Geschiss eintragen
Bestimmt
Noch kein Oracle Kunde
Wisst ihr was wir probieren das mal schnell aus
Lass mal schnell
Checken
Ich melde mich mal in einer
Incognito Session an
Ich glaube die haben keine 10 Minuten Mail angenommen
Wollte Kreditkarte
Ja Kreditkarte können die haben
Da mach ich mir einfach so eine temporäre in der App
Ok Gebiet
Albanien Afghanistan
Amerikanisch Samoa
Wo zum Teufel ist
Irgendwo im Meer auf jeden Fall
Oh das sieht da mega nice da aus
In Amerikanisch Samoa
Alter
Alter das sieht richtig krass aus
In Amerikanisch Samoa
Ich hab keine Ahnung wo das ist
Aber das sieht ja mega nice da aus
Das ist ein Militär Sturzpunkt
Ach deswegen haben die so eine befestigte Brücke
Aber es sieht mega nice aus in Amerikanisch Samoa
Richtig
Amerikanisch Samoa
Wie viele Einwohner hat das?
49.000
Und wie groß?
200 km nur
200 km2
Ok das ist wirklich
Kann man eine Urlaub machen?
Das sieht mega nice aus
Ich fahre da nicht wirklich hin
Aber was machen die denn da?
Ok es ist Wikipedia
Kann ja nichts Schlimmes sein
Kann man eine Urlaub machen
in Amerikanisch Samoa?
Von Neuseeland
Ach du Kacke Alter
Das Alter
Ok das ist
Das scheint mir echt am Arsch der Welt
Das scheint mir echt am Arsch
Ok lass mal schnell probieren
Deutschland
So lass mal
Deutschland Vorname
Max Kacke
E-Mail
Leute ihr müsst kurz weg
Ich trag eine echte E-Mail ein
Aber auch Fake
Also echte Fake-Mail
Die ich aber jederzeit wieder löschen kann
Klicken sie auf eins
Der Bilder mit dem Strommast
Ok alles klar
Strommast Capture
Jawoll
Meine E-Mail Adresse verifizieren
Ja ein Verifizierungslink wurde
geschickt. Ja Leute ihr könnt gleich wieder gucken
Ich muss den Verifizierungslink
verifizieren
Verifizierungslink Twitch
Successful
Verify your E-Mail Adress
By clicking on this link below
Wisst ihr Leute ich hasse E-Mails
die in plain text nicht
zu lesen sind
Klicke auf den Link
E-Mail ist jetzt bestätigt
Alter Oracle
geht ja schon gut los
Verify E-Mail
E-Mail ist verifiziert
Geben sie ein gültiges Passwort ein
Ja mach ich auch
Ok
Passwort
Ja, bestes, bestes Passwort
Kein Wort
Nice
Account
Cloud-Account-Name
Oracle4M heißt das jetzt einfach
Leute, ich kann euch
gleich wieder einplenden
Was?
Europe
Germany, Frankfurt
Ich bin zu dumm
Ich weiß nicht wie es funktioniert
Stimmen sie den Nutzungsbedingungen zu
Leute, das Ding ist so schlecht
Die Anmeldung funktioniert noch nicht mal
Noch nicht mal
Okay jetzt
Alles klar, auf gehts
Oh Mist, okay jetzt hat es sich erledigt
Leute, es hat sich erledigt
Es hat sich erledigt
Und außerdem habe ich die E-Mail Adresse geleakt
Ich habe einfach eine Test
Ich habe eine E-Mail Adresse schnell weitergeleitet
von Cloudflare
Okay, das ist ein Scheinpflicht
Das wir
Ach fuck, Alter
Was soll dieser Mist, Alter
Kreditkarte hätte ich ja eingegeben
Aber warum immer Telefonnummer?
Kann man da Fake-Shit eingeben?
Kann man da irgendwelchen Fake-Mists eingeben?
Es gibt temporäre, aber jetzt ist doch alles möglich.
Kek W Street 1
Verifizierungsmethode für Zahlungen hinterlegen
Kek W Street 2
Einwegkarte
Die expired im Jahr 2028
Es ging einfach
Es hat mit Einweg Kreditkarte einfach funktioniert
easy
Fehler kommt jetzt ok ok schauen wir mal
Close
Ja
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ja dann mache ich halt keine oracle
cloud
verwendung von prepaid karten ja
dann halt nicht
back to stern sein aber keine oracle cloud
wenn sie mich nicht registrieren lassen wollen
wenn sie mich nicht registrieren lassen wollen haben sie halt pech gehabt
ich meine das ist jetzt nicht so unbedingt wichtig also ich brauche die ich brauche das jetzt nicht
unbedingt ich habe mir nur gedacht lasst mal das lasst mal das freetier schnell testen wenn wir
schon gerade mal hier sind ja ich loge mich mal kurz in cloudflare ein und lösche die
temporäre email adresse tja hab irgendwas habe ich irgendwas vergessen ja was ist die
woche irgendwas spannendes passiert was heißt die woche ist ja montag keck die woche hat ja
erst angefangen ich frage am sonntag wieder du hast seit gestern ticket bei denen offen
die werden wahrscheinlich dich nicht ergreifen direkt wieder direkt wieder sperren ich mein
die wollen halt offensichtlich keine prepaid karten und insofern pech gehabt
ich habe mal die email adresse wieder deaktiviert
äh wie kann man checken ob es sich um eine prepaid karte handelt ich vermute mal dass
du das als normalsterblicher gar nicht checken kannst sondern das wirst du wahrscheinlich
nur in zusammenarbeit wenn du irgendwie business tarif hast mit den kreditkartenanbietern checken
können also ich gehe mal davon aus dass das eher gut meine kreditkartenanbieter weiß es ja wie
gesagt also das wirst du als normalsterblicher gar nicht testen können so ich
werde mal kurz meine single use kreditkarte löschen
was witzigerweise nicht geht ich habe mir eine one way kreditkarte gemacht und der
sinn davon ist eigentlich dass man die easy löschen kann
terminate card yes ok ok kann man einfach nicht löschen
ah moment ich bin ja auch doof der hatte ja schon längst gelöscht das ist einfach immer wieder
eine neue die da anlegt ok das ist aber bescheuert gemacht so alles klar nice enden wir das auch
oracle cloud registrierung sehr pepega die email adresse muss unverdächtig aussehen ja findest du
nicht dass oracle vm adkappalull.com irgendwie verdächtig ist du hast dein praktikum begonnen
nice irgendjemand auch erzählte hat seinen neuen job unterschrieben wer war denn das
wollte ich doch wissen was es ist
da nicht weiß ich ob er darauf geantwortet hat ich finde es jetzt gar nicht mehr
ah gut pech gehabt
nee ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert ich wollte das tatsächlich mal in einem der
nächsten streams ausprobieren wie es mit hetzer und arm aussieht von der idee her ist das eigentlich
ganz cool gerade weil du halt fast doppelt so viel ram bekommst du bist cloud security engineer
def sack ops aber das ist aber viel zu wenig ich dachte heutzutage muss man mindestens def
sack win bis sack ops sein oder sowas in der richtung gucken wir mal zurück zurück zum
thema da gucken wir noch okay wir fangen bei der wir fangen bei der räudigsten seite überhaupt
an wir gucken wir gucken bei guld im prinzipen listen die eh überall ja so komm wir gucken mal
okay eigentlich eigentlich ist für unseren fall ja vollkommen vollkommen egal kann man nicht
einfach sagen überall vollkommen egal wo wir gucken ja suchen wir mal in frankfurt aber wir
haben halt umkreis eng merken merken was haben die denn diese die seiten die sachen müssen
wir uns nicht angucken die sind meistens relativ langweilig schwerpunkt software da lachen sie
wieder sind immer so glücklich dass sie dort arbeiten dürfen alle so und dann haben wir hier
noch mal stepson gucken wir auch mal da job titel def sec bis wenn man dafür noch nicht mal sachen
löschen die haben wieder ihre suche verkackt achtung flash bang kommt wir suchen wir suchen mal
nach ach hier kann man auch so komplett machen so und wir suchen in frankfurt wie gesagt ist
ja eh nicht für mich ich bleib erstmal da wo ich bin kann man nicht einfach den radius und
man kann wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifend die location weglassen oder nimmt er dann
irgendwas in der nähe ne hannover münchen ne ne dann okay dann nimmt tatsächlich irgendwo
irgendwas lass uns mal gucken was es da aktuelles gibt ja wieder ganz viele glückliche leute am start
sap consultancy oh ne da habe ich auch überhaupt keinen plan von deswegen kann ich kann ich mich
noch nicht mal drüber lustig machen weil ich keine ahnung von ab hast du keine lust
mehr auf windows und sucht schon wieder was neues nein ich habe im stream heute einfach
schlicht und ergreifend gefragt was wollen wir denn mal machen wie wäre es mal wieder mit
stellen anzeigen ich suche nichts neues
ok
die haben alle so mehr oder weniger gleich die datengrundlage oder also was haben die
denn hier mal gucken ob abgedrehte sachen heute wieder dabei sind ich habe ja mittlerweile schon
ganz gutes gespür dafür irgendwelche bescheuerten stellenanzeigen zu finden
wir müssen nachher übrigens noch bist du jetzt immer noch am ober x ja bin ich immer noch
wisst ihr was wir nachher noch machen müssen wir müssen uns unbedingt noch mal das video angucken
von vom bauer oder von hardware deals ist es glaube ich hardware reviews hardware deals heißt
und das hetsa rechenzentrum müssen wir uns da mal angucken ich habe gesehen dass sie ein
video hochgeladen haben das wollte das wollte ich mir noch mal anschauen also ausgezeichnet als top
innovator da kann ja eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen der software die will aber schwerpunkt
defops mws okay ich gebe zu ich bringe den witz nicht der witz hat so ein bad mittlerweile schon
ich wollte sagen warum suchen die immer nur männlich weiß deutsch aber mittlerweile ich
glaube beim zehnten mal ist es auch nicht mal lustig ok bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla gestaltet bei frankfurter bla bla bla ok also du entwickelst software nach kundenanforderungen
ja ok du erstellst business skripte seriously leute ich habe keine ahnung was business skripte sind
kann mir das jemand erklären also ich meine ich bin jetzt erst seit seit 16 16 jahren da in diesem
bruder ich weiß nicht was business skripte sind wer kennt sie nicht die business skripte in java
ja tatsächlich aber es ist nicht du bist verantwortlich für das verfassen von
konfiguration und automatisierung zum beispiel in xml und jason what das ergibt überhaupt keinen
sinn also heutzutage ist man mehr jammel engineer als sonst was kann das zufällig sein dass die
leute die die stellenanzeige geschrieben haben wieder überhaupt nicht wissen was
oder sie sind so old school dass sie nur java java xml ich weiß nicht aber
ich würde fast wetten das meiste ist bei denen auch jammel
schande über dich dass die business skripte nix sagen ja feels bad man
hatte jetzt eine anzeige zugesend bekommt von einem recruiter mit unter
anderen den vorteil partnerschaftliches aber in traditionen zu nehmen und
weiterbild naja das sind so nur nach 15 sprüche das sagt ja das sagt
tatsächlich noch nicht immer wirklich was drüber aus ob es gut oder schlecht
das sagt eigentlich gar nichts aus die firmen denken die unternehmen denken
irgendwie immer nur dass diese punkte diese punkte ziehen ich glaube eh dass
personen dass die personalabteilung in der regel im kopf bisschen anders tickt
als zumindest zumindest leute aus der alti die den job suchen weil das was
dort als ho das müssen wir unbedingt reinschreiben und das macht bestimmt
krasse pluspunkte gesehen wird ist eher so was wo sich die meisten alti leute
denken oh ne bitte nicht ja zum beispiel zum beispiel was ich total total oft
lese in stellen anzeigen ist so was nach dem motto ja ich brauche jetzt mal so eine
coole formulierung wie es da immer drinne steht
da steht immer so was wie coole team events so was gibt es nur bei uns coole
team events und so was wo ich mir schon immer denke alter ich will keine coole
team events lasst mich in ruhe ich will da arbeiten geld verdienen
naja so den ein oder anderen spaß haben an der arbeit ja schon aber für coole
coole team event 24 sie muss nicht sein lasst mir lasst mir einfach die ruhe
ja ok also automatisierung konfiguration xml und jason na gut wollen
wir mal nicht wollen wir mal nicht zu picky sein und und nehmen wir das einfach
mal hin auch wenn auch wenn ich wette dass es nicht stimmt bei denen
das ist wahrscheinlich zum grüß ans trinken erinnere hast du recht
trinken exzellent
aber getrunken ok also wollen wir mal nicht zu sehr auf details rum
reiten wahrscheinlich wusste derjenige der das geschrieben hat schlichter
greift nicht dass man heute fast alles in jammeln macht aber ok also leute wenn
ihr übrigens gute stellenanzeigen habt jetzt also gut mit gut meine ich zwei
Sachen entweder stellenanzeigen wo ihr denkt what the fuck ist das können sie
mir ruhig schicken und falls ihr welche habt wo ich mal einen blick drauf werfen
soll sei es dass ihr euch bewerben wollt oder dass die von euch ist mache ich auch
gerne im stream ich meine so lange sie zeigen darf natürlich hatten wir hier
schon ein paar mal was ich auch immer sehr lustig finde wenn ab und zu mal
jemand in stream kommen sagt max zeigt doch mal unsere neuen stellenanzeigen
ich habe sogar schon mal eine e-mail bekommen wo jemand gefragt hat ob ich
quasi konsulten konsulten kann für mich konsulten kann für IT stellenanzeigen
geiler ja kann ich machen und ich wollte den schon
weiterleiten an meinen koordinator für so sponsorings aber am ende hat er halt
gemeint sie können mir halt nichts bezahlen sondern sie können mir halt
ein t-shirt von ihrem laden schicken also ich brauche kein t-shirt von euch und
weißt du was kurz drauf gucken mache ich auch so aber alles weitere nicht für
t-shirt ja das war super hippo start-up geht wobei ich weiß gar nicht mehr doch
doch doch da war irgendwas start-up mäßiges
ok als teil des teams also t-shirts mit t-shirts kannst du mich nicht schocken
mit t-shirts open source ich weiß nicht ich weiß immer noch nicht wie man dich
ausspricht aber poggers was du wieder am start bist mit t-shirts kannst mich nicht
locken mit kappen kannst du mich locken allerdings nicht diese normalen kappen
ich habe keine ahnung wie die heißen also es gibt ja quasi so diese normalen
baseball caps und es gibt die dead caps die mag ich die mag ich leute ich bin
jetzt fast 39 darf dead caps mögen dead caps und baseball cap sind so die
bisschen anderen so die hier die da die mag ich nicht also die mal die hier
finde ich cool von vom schnitt her die ich nicht mag sind die mit dem tja wo
sind es denn also die so gerade vorne sind die mag ich nicht die kann man sich
so selber biegen das das sagt so ein bisschen ich ich mag so eher so die was
die golf die die golfspieler an haben also mit so kappen kannst du mich locken
ja da würde ich mir vielleicht auch was für angucken
ich habe jede menge kappen am start und ich habe nichts dagegen noch etwas mehr
kappen zu haben mützen sind ja eigentlich so also was haben wir als
teil des teams bist du zuständig für das anbinden an extra no tools zum
beispiel der rest api für workflow automatisierungsprojekte
ok ja warum nicht passt ja passt ja eigentlich ganz gut hin beste mütze
also was ich mir kaufen wollte ist tatsächlich half life so was hier in
der richtung habe ich letztens in irgendeinem shop gesehen und also auch gerade so mit ein
bisschen so used look da hätte ich bock drauf so was in der richtung so eine half life mütze
ja chat kann mir immer noch keiner erklären was was in business script sagt halt mal
ok die software administration und die fehleranalyse liegen ebenfalls in
deinem verantwortungsbereich ja was ist so immer die frage was liegt nicht in meinem
verantwortungsbereich die software administration was verstehen die jetzt genau darunter das ist
auch wieder sehr umfangreich alles oder du programmierst software du administrieren
irgendwas du automatisierst du erstellst business skripte was auch immer du verstehst
dich als dienstleister für deine kunden das kommt drauf an wenn ihr ordentlich bezahlt dann dann
schon wobei für mich ist es sehr ähnlich ich sage es jetzt noch mal bevor es wieder 100.000
fragen kommen max suchst du schon was neues nein nein das ist nicht für mich dein profil
abgeschlossen das ingenieur studium der fachrichtung informatik vergleichbare ausbildung
erste kenntnisse mit software lösungen bereich monitoren so wie network configuration fehler
und performance ja gut das kann man tatsächlich erwarten monitorungen netzwerk und generell
config management als der das ist tatsächlich sehr sinnig und das würde ich auch davon ausgehen
das sollte jemand wissen der sich darauf bewirbt erste kenne ok gute kenntnisse der programmier
sprachen ja xml ok leute ist xml eine programmier sprache ja oder nein und denkt nach weil weil
also normalerweise sagt man ja nein aber ich bin mir nicht sicher was für
absonderungen mittlerweile in xml alles möglich sind
ok shell scripting bash
das ist gut 5 hat mods am start ja gut gutes command ok gute gelobte shell scripting bash
ja ok das ist auch php ok das ist jetzt schon eine geile mischung hier kommst du von java
backend automatisierung auf einmal ist random einfach mal php drinne
kennnisse mit datenbanken sql mysql maria db meinen die vielleicht mssql oder was genau ich
meine das ist eine datenbank das ist eine datenbank aber das ist keine datenbank sondern
was allgemeines na gut von vorteil erfahrung in portokollen das ist ja komplett random
ethernet okay quaint wie genau soll meine erfahrung bitteschön damit aussehen wollen
die dass ich layer 2 encoding aus dem kopf sagen kann das ist doch blöd das hat das ding hat
irgendjemand geschrieben der eigentlich überhaupt keine ahnung hat von dem was gebraucht wird
und dann kommt noch snmp dahinter ok wahrscheinlich für netzwerkgeräte weil
die haben sie auch was mit das ist sehr random irgendwie sowie kenntnis im umgang mit ritt ok
shit erfahrung ist immer gut das passt aber auch tatsächlich dazu gute deutschen englisch
kenntnisse mobiles deine vorteile oder bin ich ja mal gespannt wie viele leute wir suchen gleich
mal home office only jobs lass uns das gleich mal gleich gucken wir home office only das ist
stellenamt zeige von der personal abteilung die wirklich keine ahnung hat was gesucht wird aber
ist nicht schlecht also nicht richtig schlecht die ist schlecht die ist schlecht genug dass ich mich
nicht darauf bewerben würde wenn ich was suchen würde was ich nicht mache aber das ist also es
gibt durchaus schlechteres ist aber bisschen für also die personal abteilung hätte wirklich
keine ahnung was also noch was lustiges von meiner bewerbung ich habe ja ein ex-kollege
quasi mitgenommen zum neuen job der jetzt wieder mein aktueller kollege ist weil ich
bin ich war da ich weiß das habe ich auch schon erzählt aber nur kurz zur einleitung und ich
war ja da mein vorstellungsgespräch gehalten und als ich dann raus bin vom vorstellungsgespräch
als gut alles gut gelaufen ist habe ich halt gesagt hier ich habe gesehen ihr habt sucht ja noch eine
zweite stelle in der richtung ich hätte da noch einen habt den die bewerbungsunterlagen von meinem
kollege in die hand gedrückt und die haben ihn den tag danach angerufen da wurde dann auch
eingestellt so aber was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte ist der musste sich ja dann auch noch der
form halber übers bewerbungsportal bewerben und ich habe jetzt im nachhinein was rausgekriegt weil
wir hatten damals damals das problem mein kollege hat sich übers bewerbungsportal auf die falsche
stelle beworben nämlich auf meine aus versehen dabei wollte er sich für die andere bewerben was
dann ein bisschen für verwirrung in der personalabteilung gesorgt hat und jetzt und jetzt wissen wir auch
warum jetzt jetzt wissen wir jetzt wissen wir auch warum das so einfach warum man sich da auch so
einfach tun konnte der chef von meinem kollege hat schlicht und ergreif von meinem jetzigen chef
die stellenanzeige abgeschrieben das war exakt die gleiche stellenanzeige bis auf die schriftgröße
war unterschiedlich einfach gerippt kein wunder dass man sich da vertun konnte zwar exakt die
gleiche stellenanzeige ok was haben sie denn zu bieten deine vorteile ok das sind quasi
die vorteile die ich habe wenn ich da hingehe versteht es richtig ja mobiles arbeiten wenn
ihr wirklich sicher werdet und überzeugen wollen würdet dann würdet ihr ein bisschen mehr dazu
hinschreiben weil so wirkt das auf mich als jemand der in der firma gearbeitet hat und
sehr schlechte erfahrungen mit versprechungen gemacht hat in der vergangenheit ja gerade was
das thema homeoffice angeht ich habe euch das schon oft genug erzählen also ich muss es heute
nicht ausführen ich habe sogar videos darüber gemacht für mich ist es verdächtig wenn da
jemand hinschreibt mobiles arbeiten beziehungsweise das wort homeoffice irgendwie auch vermeidet und
nichts konkretes hinschreibt was ja weil das wirkt so als schreibt man das hin dass sich
überhaupt leute bewerben und am ende ist es dann so was wie ja so einmal im monat wenn die bahn
streikt dürfte auch mal von daheim arbeiten so was was auch moment bahn nicht das morgen sekunde
das modell der das sap homeoffice was macht denn sap
mittwoch für strah auch fickt euch alter die gehen mir auf den sack nix hinbekommen ja gut
da können die leute ja nichts dafür die bei der bahn arbeiten aber nix hinbekommen und dann auch
jetzt noch streiken ihr könnt mich mal alter der drecksladen mann öffis das klingt immer so
das klingt immer so niedlich mit was fährst du ich fahre mit den öffis mittwoch
gut dass ich mittwoch homeoffice habe der verkehr mit alter ist ja gut
ich mag seiten nicht wo auf einmal irgendwelche audiosachen anfangen zu
spielen ok strukturiert ist strukturiert ist ein umfangreiches on-board mit mentoren ist
dabei alles klar nice das ist tatsächlich ein vorteil allerdings muss man sehen dass
es für beide seiten ein vorteil weil seriously wenn man die leute gut einarbeitet und die dann
auch was gescheites machen können ist ja nicht nur der vorteil für den mitarbeiter sondern auch
ganz klar der vorteil für den arbeitgeber allerdings finde ich es tatsächlich ein plus
weil ich habe es auch schon erlebt dass die einarbeitung quasi nicht existent ist und man
sich dann darüber beschwert im nachhinein so vielfältige was am mittwoch finden die
abschlussprüfung haben die das absichtlich über auf die abschlussprüfung gelegt die
haben das letzte mal mussten sie es auch schon verschieben weil der download nicht funktioniert
habt ihr das mitbekommen die konnten ja in irgendeinem bundesland ich weiß ich meine
welche in irgendeinem bundesland konnten die die abiturprüfung nicht schreiben weil der
download nicht funktioniert hat richtig pepega war jemand von euch betroffen frage
wir haben bestimmt auch ein paar jüngere war jemand war jemand von euch betroffen
die fachinformatiker prüfung sind auch mit ja das war legendär ich frag mich halt echt wie
sowas passieren kann ich glaube das sind zwei sachen unfähige leute die die IT projekte
umsetzen und die lehrer sind eutechnisch nicht so oft zack das ist eine kombination aus bei
dem jaja guckt mal also wenn ihr mal news sucht hier downloads selbst downloads zu schwer für
die deutsche verwaltung gut ich glaube der artikel ist bis sie bis sie einseitig geschrieben ja kann
schon seit da scheitert viel am geld also ganz im ernst wenn ich das hier lese was sie da machen
müssen irgendwelche 7zip archife die dann extrahiert werden müssen ich habe ich habe
hier gibt es irgendwo die anleitung es gab die anleitung gab es öffentlich zu sehen dazu das
war schon sehr pepega gemacht und sich auch fragt wie kann das wie kann das eigentlich sein
ja das meine ich doch dass das meine ich doch hier genau das meine ich doch hier da kann man
sich die anleitung angucken guck mal cooles nrw also wenn man wenn man die also das war ja so
gedacht dass die lehrer diese prüfung irgendwie im vorfeld hier runterladen und aus entpacken mit
irgendeinem password ja so du brauchst irgendwelche zugangsdaten da musst du dich anmelden und das
wie gesagt das wird noch komplizierter download starten speichern ausführen dann auf ein usb
stück dann musst du es entschlüsseln allerdings irgendwie auf den windows laufwerk dann musst du
entpacken dann musst du den passwort für die zip datei eingeben dann ist es aus irgendwelchen
gründen selbst entpackendes archiv mit mit eigenem logo drinne natürlich muss muss sein
dann auf die prüfsumme checken also ich kann verstehen dass die leute es erstmal nicht gecheckt
haben allerdings auf der anderen seite hätte man das ja im vorfeld machen können es gab ja wohl
demo dateien deswegen würde ich halt sagen das ist wieder auf dem auf beides beidseiten mists
ja dass man sieht wie der fehler aussieht auf beidseiten beidseiten der miske die lehrer sind
nicht sonderlich fähig was IT sachen angeht und die leute die das umgesetzt haben ist auch schon
ja ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt nicht warum man da nicht einfachen webportal macht was man quasi
nur wo man keine ahnung sich als lehrer registrieren kann oder irgendwas keine gibt
es ja schon durchaus möglichkeiten und auf diesem portal wird schlicht und ergreifend
eine eine datei angeboten die kann sie die müssen das machen wie steam die müssen das
machen wie steam du kannst die dateien schon im vorfeld runterladen aber du kannst sie quasi
erst am dann und dann quasi zugreifen und da gibt es ja hunderte möglichkeiten für an auch
an fertigen services wie man das wie man das machen kann das ist schon ein bisschen wir
gut lass mal hier kurz fertig gucken also also freiraum um eigene kreativ ein tolles arbeitsumfeld
wo wir wieder beim thema sind mit regelmäßigen mitarbeiterevents das ist so dieser punkt wo
ich glaube das personaler denken das ist ein super nice vorteil so nach dem motto wir haben
da was tolles was könnten wir da noch einschreiben regelmäßige mitarbeiterevents und die leute
denken sich in wirklichkeit ja ja genau das denken die sich genau genau das das trifft
es eigentlich ganz gut das ist auf jeden fall kein vorteil für mich ich muss irgendwann
ende des jahres schon auf irgendeinen komischen team building workshop wieder habe ich schon
keinen bock drauf und das liegt nicht an den leuten ich habe einfach keinen bock wenn die
arbeit fertig ist noch was mit der arbeit zu tun zu haben gut ist aber ist aber höchstwahrscheinlich
alles arbeitszeit dann soll mir das recht sein was ist denn mit deinen tabs los wieso
die sehen noch fresh aus meine tabs wie man das heutzutage nennt ich habe sogar noch mehr
kostenfreie mitarbeiter das ist wirklich ein vorteil das ist wirklich mal ein vorteil
die sollten wenn sie es richtig machen wollen die sollten oben hinschreiben homeoffice abmachung
oder sowas wie was ist 80 prozent homeoffice möglich kostenfreie mitarbeiter parkplätze so wenn
die sowas haben hier dann sollte das in der kombinat in der reinfolge stehen neue arbeitsplatz
ausstattung in einem repräsentativen gebäude was neue arbeitsplätze die meinen moderne moderne
arbeitsplatz ausstatt nicht neue also dass man dass ich dass ich nichts kriege was schon klebt
wo einer drei jahre draufgeschwitzt hat so nach dem motto das würde ich mal von ausgehen die meinen
die wollen wahrscheinlich sagen moderne moderne ausstattung moderne arbeitsplatz ausstattung
wenn man wenn man einen höhenverstellbaren schreibtisch und solche geschichten hat ich
würde es tatsächlich erwähnen das ist für mich auch ein plus und wenn es beispielsweise
handys gibt die privat benutzt werden dürfte finde ich das auch ein plus sollte man alles
hinschreiben wird offensichtlich gemacht und ich weiß nicht warum repräsentativen ob das
gebäude repräsentativ ist oder nicht wäre mir vollkommen egal altersversorgungsangebote
im kostenlosen ja kann man okay kopeck gut das haben sie alle das ist habe ich noch nie was
gekauft hatten hatten alle arbeitgeber bisher wo ich gewesen bin habe ich noch nie unsinnig
kaffee und t-spezialitäten gehen bei uns aufs haus ok man kann quasi kaffee kostenlos trinken flache
hierarchie hohe wertschätzung sowie kurze kommunikations- und entscheidungswege er hat
mich jetzt nicht so überzeugt aber weit davon entfernt leute weit davon entfernt
richtig schlecht zu sein der denik guck mal der denik sucht leute das doch mal was ich
kenne ich kenne den ehemaligen chef vom denik dem habe ich jetzt paar jahre zusammen gearbeitet
was jetzt nicht heißt dass ich genau wüsste was der denik macht ich meine klar wir kennen
den denik vom registrieren von de domains aber was sie so wirklich sonst noch alles machen
habe ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keine ahnung
der fops engineer internal services system engineer wieder momentlich weiß deutsch
du liebst deinen job aber es ist zeit für etwas neues war bei mir so ich bin ja seit
knapp ganz knapp ne monat jetzt im neuen job das reicht mir auch erst mal ich suche jetzt
nicht erstmal nicht etwas neues ist golem stepstone besser als sing linked in nee das
nimmt sich alles nix über sing wirste halt beziehungsweise linkedin wirst halt eher voll
gespammt von irgendwelchen coaches ähnlich coaches wie komme ich auf coaches von
irgendwelchen headhunter leuten die dein profil nicht mal richtig gelesen haben und
eher auf massestandsklasse setzen in der hoffnung sie vermitteln ab und zu mal ein
gehören die zu d6 nein nein d6 hat nichts mit denic zu tun denic ist dort wo die deutschen
dns beziehungsweise dort vor die wo die für deutsche domains zu steht steht auch steht
auch hier oben guck mal technische stabilität der wichtigen ressorts deutsches 17 millionen
die sind das d6 sind die mit dem internetknoten punkt in frankfurt und frag mich nicht frag mich
nicht wo noch aber ich kenne den in frankfurt auf der hanauer landstraße da wo man sich wiegen
muss und wenn man auf dem clover innen nicht mehr rauskommt ne man kann innen nicht aufs
klo glaube ich also was haben die hier übernimmt verantwortet für sehr kräftige neue greift
die chance reizende möglichkeit aus lernen unsere selbst organisierten cross funktionalen
agilen teams kennen da geht es aber los hier die sind sowas von web 5.0 ok du unterstützt
uns bei der weit und dem betrieb unserer intern it dienst ja klingt ja sinnig du fühlst dich
in den system und infrastruktur betreuen zu hause klingt auch sehr sinnig dafür zu unserem
technologie stack zählen unter anderem linux vor allem der scalar und ich habe keine ahnung
was scalar ist weiß gelter terraform automation ok ich weiß nicht was es ist
docker kubernetes postgres padroni sagt was ist padroni für postgres igne cluster geschichte
template high availability template template for postgres ein template für was template für
ein template für was ist a template
ach so die meinen damit dass ich das noch füllen muss mit
werten und sachen die dass es bei mir richtig funktioniert ok postgres ha jenkins solstek
maria db galera was war galera noch mal also maria db sagt mir was galera habe ich auch schon
mal gehört müsste ich jetzt einmal pauschal nicht senzu alter dass ich das noch erleben darf dass
ich mal wirklich den laden sehe der tatsächlich senzu benutzt grafana prometheus die monitoren
sich aber auch hier den hinteren wund aber gut das klingt sehr sinnvoll ja muss ja nicht alles
kennen also ich mein ja sagt mir was logisch ja scalar keine ahnen docker ja kopenhetes ja
ist das wo ich aktuell auch viel mit mache postgres ja jenkins auch klar sollsack auch
schon mal gesehen aber das ist ein bisschen was wie ansible also wer sich jetzt fragt was sollsack
was in richtung von ansible ist das maria db ja senso habe ich auch schon mal gehört wusste
nicht dass das überhaupt jemand verwendet kafala prometo ist auch klar klingt mich jetzt auch ganz
gut in unserem team betreust du unsere internen it dienste jira conference oder wie die coolen
leute bei mir früher auf der arbeit gesagt haben gyra
waren das die selben die schütz sagen ne also jira finde ich ja noch ok aber gyra klingt
einfach zu zu möchte gern cool du legst wert darauf aufgaben möglichst zu automatisieren
ok passt mein zu dem job passt das wirklich gut informationssicherheit hohe verfügbarkeit
und geht ein profilschule einschläge wurden und jede kennt jetzt die lindungsadministration
grundlagen know-how netzwerk also ich habe hier virtualisierung container monitoring
datenbanken ja also ich muss sagen hätte ich nicht schon einen neuen job finde ich das hier
bis jetzt gar nicht mal so übel erfahrungen in der nutzung von automatisierungs tools jenkins
keine ahnung habe ich nie benutzt cd pipelines
der trend geht allerdings dahin gerade im kubernetes umfeld dass man ci und cd trend also man hat
dann irgendein continuous integration system zum beispiel jenkins oder github actions oder
sowas und am ende hat man noch ein continuous delivery system bspw. sowas wie flux oder
agucd in kubernetes wer die sachen dann applied also macht das heutzutage oftmals in mehreren
steps plus punkt kenntnisse da kann man dann übrigens auch letztens hat auch irgendjemand
gefragt wie macht man dann am besten datenbank migration in kubernetes ja und da wobei ich weiß
gar nicht mehr ist ist derjenige im chat ich weiß es gar nicht mehr gar nicht mehr was ich
da drauf gesagt habe ich glaube nur ich habe gesagt dass datenbanken in kubernetes keine gute
idee sind allerdings ich habe nicht daran gedacht dass die datenbank ja gar nicht in kubernetes
laufen muss dafür dass man die datenbank migration aus der kubernetes anwendung anstoßen möchte
und dafür ist wunderbar man hat ein continuous delivery system weil dort kann man quasi schon
im pre deploys depp die datenbank migration machen an einer stelle und da muss man keine
custom logik für bauen also aus dem gesichtspunkt ist das eigentlich sehr sinnvolle
geschichte nur noch mal zu dem wo was letztens von hatten ne würde ich auch nicht machen also
zumindest zumindest würde ich es nicht selbst machen wenn ich irgendwo eine managed datenbank
kaufe und die lassen die irgendwie auf kubernetes laufen soll sich mein problem sein python und
pap haben noch migrate steps ja es hat so gut wie jedes web framework migrate steps für datenbank
migrations die sache ist plus die wenn deine anwendung stell dir mal vor du hast eine anwendung
im kubernetes cluster laufen und aktuell läuft die anwendung auf 12 replikas übertreiben wir
mal ein bisschen das heißt wenn du jetzt die anwendung upgradest sagen wir so immer so vier
container auf einmal so rolling update und macht der kubernetes im hintergrund automatisch dann
hast du vier container die versuchen gleichzeitig oder mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig die
datenbank migration zu starten und ob das so eine gute idee ist sei mal dahingestellt
ja das kannst du machen das wie gesagt das gibt mehrere möglichkeiten wie du machen kannst
so ursprünglich haben die leute gesagt nehmen in it container ja wobei das auch nicht so schlau
ist weil in it container werden auch pro replica einer gestartet also das sinnigste wäre wahrscheinlich
tatsächlich irgend so ein background kubernetes job der guckt ob was ansteht oder so müsstest
dir aber auch selbst bauen das heißt am besten ist tatsächlich das was finde ich das was ich
gerade vorgeschlagen habe und zwar dass man das im continuous delivery step macht also sprich
dass du irgendeinen pre hook precinct heißt glaube ich bei agro cd hack hochkasten also
irgendwie predeployment step wo du die datenbankmigration machst an einer stelle
und dann machst du weiter also dafür lohnt sich das tatsächlich und es ist so ein bisschen der
aktuelle trend dass man das hier und das hier auf splittet auch wenn es immer so in einem
atemzug genannt wird ja also mir fällt jetzt kein migration system ein was irgendwie supporten
würde parallel mehrere migration also das kann eigentlich nur probleme geben und wenn selbst wenn
die datenbank locks hat fängst du dir probleme ein weil deine container erst mal crashen beim
ersten start also das ist alles keine gute idee was machst du dann wenn das deployment nicht
durchläuft rollback wäre möglich ja komm ein bisschen drauf an wie du deine sagen ja also je
nach dem was du verwendest kannst du es auch zurückrollen es ist aber eh es ist ein bisschen
ein bisschen problematisch mit datenbankmigration ich muss auch sagen ich habe da praktisch also ich
habe noch nie sowas selbst gebaut im im zu im wie soll man sagen im kubernetes umfeld also ich
meine ich habe schon sachen betreut wo datenbankmigration laufen muss aber ich habe
noch nie sowas mit designt dass man on the fly eine anwendung in kubernetes upgraden kann und
dahinter musste datenbankmigration laufen weil das ding ist ja so man muss ja dann auch ganz
höllisch aufpassen was man da migrated weil die alten container laufen ja auch noch und
je nachdem wenn du wirklich so einen super high availability rolling update machen willst
dann willst du ja auch nicht dass die alten container abkacken beziehungsweise die user
die noch da drauf sind nicht weiterarbeiten können also du brauchst quasi ein schema
ein neues schema was das alte erweitert aber nicht inkompatibel zum alten ist also das ist
auf jeden fall nicht nicht so einfach wie sich vielleicht auf den ersten blick darstellt und
wenn du da eine einfache vm hast mit einer web anwendung drauf und du deploys das und machst
ein migration step ist auf jeden fall einfacher also was in einem kombiniertes cluster zu hand haben
ne ich weiß was das habe ich noch nicht benutzt also mit argo cd kannst du rollbacks machen wie
gesagt ich habe da keine so wie nennt man so schön hands-on erfahrung so was zu designen
ich würde das aber tatsächlich gerne mal machen weil ich das ist sehr spannendes thema wie
designt man eine wirklich hoch verfügbare anwendung in kubernetes die im hintergrund
datenbank migration machen muss bei versions updates vielleicht sollte man sich prinzipiell
überlegen ob man nicht die anwendung anders designt dass man zum beispiel die anwendung
nur über irgendeinen extra api zwischen zwischen step auf die datenbank zugreifen lässt oder
craftql oder sowas davor hat wobei man sich dann halt fragen muss ok vielleicht muss ich ja mal
das craftql ding auch updaten beziehungsweise die datenbank ja irgendwie beißt sich da in den
schwanz kann man auch machen ja wie gesagt gibt er gibt er mehrere ansätze für das problem dann
ist wieder die frage wo lässt du dein helm deployment laufen von hand oder in irgendeinem
continuous integration continuous delivery post build step oder nach klick nach klick auf
web interface job und dann deployment wie bist du darauf gekommen das kann ich dir sagen wie
ich auf mein avatar gekommen bin es ist eigentlich hat mit keksen ursprünglich also mit dem jetzigen
avatar gar nichts zu tun ich hatte ich hatte mal ganz ganz ursprünglich ein linux tux keks bild
cookie keine ahnung ob man das bild noch irgendwo findet also den keks also linux tux als keks hatte
ich mal als als avatar ganz ganz am anfang für irgendwie ein paar wochen
ich glaube das findet man nicht mehr keine ahnung vielleicht haben wir glück vielleicht
haben wir glück moment vielleicht vielleicht haben wir glück
ich muss mal kurz hier den dark wieder ausmachen vielleicht haben wir glück 2000
nicht früher
moment moment das muss es doch noch früher gegeben haben das muss es doch früher gegeben
haben noch ist es vielleicht user max fps die damalige channel page war ich gut ja
hallo 2010 ja tatsächlich poc alter mein browser ist wieder am abkacken was ist denn das für
nee browser ist nicht am abkacken, es ist einfach nur langsam
ok november
25 2011 2011 haben wir hier noch januar also wenn wir glück haben gibt es den alten avatar hier
ja hier ich hatte ich hatte so ninox kix tux kix bild ursprünglich und das konnte ich da
nicht weiter benutzen weil ich ja die rechte an dem bild nicht hab das kennst du norrad
bist du schon hier original bist schon lange dabei so und das ist die grundlage von meinem
jetzigen kix avatar bild weil ich das weil ich das damals hatte und keine ahnung wenn das ist
irgendwie das hatte ich auf irgendeiner random seite und ich dachte mir nicht dass ich irgendwie
probleme wegen dem bild bekomme wenn ich das für kommerzielle zwecke und so benutze da habe
ich mir eins machen lassen damals ja guck ich glaube also gar noch ein bisschen höher aufgelöst
man muss schon sagen war schon nice also die die alten channel pages waren schon cool dass
das ist die mittel alte also man muss halt sagen die channel pages damals waren viel viel
individueller und aus meiner sicht auch hübscher und funktionaler als die aktuellen channel pages
damals konnte man sich tatsächlich noch noch durchskollen ordentlich in den kommentaren und
sowas kommt man damals hatten das hat sich noch eher wie eine desktop webseite angefühlt
der ultra skill unboxing mit dem frasier
damals haben die leute auch schon immer gedacht dass ich jünger bin als ich als ich bin
ja na gut ok weiter weiter im text wo sind wir hier stehen geblieben also beim denik waren wir
darf man das alte pick klauen klar das ist nicht von mir los punkt kennt es einer programmiersprache
zum beispiel python go lang oder insbesondere java was ist es nur warum stehen die business leute
alle so auf java gutes deutsch und englisch in wort und schrift typ typ service orientierter
macher schnelles auffassen lösungsorientiertes vorgehen ich fand die stellenanzeige bis jetzt
eigentlich ganz gut aber typ service orientierter mach halter meine fresse engagiert im team solo
mit hoher eingefahren und immer begeistert von verbessungen nice to have kenntnisse agiler
arbeitsweisen scrum kann man okay ähm ausgewogen durchkleidung zentral gelegene mit homeoffice
möglichkeit umfangreich homeoffice möglichkeit ok also einen halben tag die woche ich glaube
die machen das tatsächlich besser kontinuier weiter mit leistung ok fahrtkosten erstattung
zuschussbezüglich altersvorsorge arbeitsgeber zu fitnesscenter und schau mal ja also im ernst
macht ein ganz oken eindruck der denik also das davor fand ich schlechter so ist durch es ist
eigentlich in ordnung ja ist in ordnung nicht dass ich mich wirklich drauf bewerben würde ich
sag aber ja also wie gesagt ich suche eh keinen job aber es ist ja nicht so dass ich auch sonst
gesagt hätte ich würde mir den fingern jucken aber ich schon ganz okay oder chat was was sagt
ihr ich meine gerade das hier oben klingt zumindest so als hat die stellenanzeige jemand
erstellt der irgendwie nur ein bisschen ahnung hat von dem was er schreibt weil deine arbeit
muss nur vier tage im monat in der arbeit sein ja ich auch einmal die woche beziehungsweise einmal
alle 14 tage je nachdem wie es wie es gerade so ist also ich bin auch quasi nur vier tage im
monat ungefähr bei der arbeit also in frankfurt morgen bin ich wieder in frankfurt was ist das
da unten für eine windows defops stelle moment wo windows windows haben wir das nicht schon
geguckt hatten wir das nicht schon mal die kommt mir irgendwie das ist da eine ok wollte gerade
sagen die kommt mir nämlich irgendwie bekannt vor warum ist eigentlich nicht 100 prozent home
office möglich weil der arbeitgeber das nicht will ich kann das auch verstehen dass man sagt
wenn man einen standort hat der nicht jetzt super weit weg ist dass man die leute ab und zu mal
sieht das finde ich das finde ich in ordnung das kann ich auch nachvollziehen irgendwo
aber mehr muss es dann halt auch nicht sein
der fobs engineer linux unos a perfect match
der von mwd schon wieder ok was bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
mit über 1000 betreiben sie modernste in den langfristigen 24 sieben system support
ok flex der job ok also der job was gibt es hier flexibles und mobiles arbeiten sie arbeiten
gemeinsam mit unseren mit unserem linux team an spannenden kunden im aviation moment aviation
ist das luftfahrt flexibles und mobiles arbeiten da hätte ich schon mal gar keinen bock drauf wenn
die dazu mir sagen übrigens nächste woche muss in hamburg arbeiten boah da hätte ich keinen bock
drauf sie sind für die installation konfiguration im betrieb sowie die weiterentwicklung von primär
auf linux basierten systemen und platform verantwortlich webserver application server
datenbank ja gut oder so schon ok viele im der formsbereich kommen ja quasi so aus dem
server admin bereich wobei eigentlich ist so die ableitung so die herkunft dieser sache was
anderes also das ist jetzt keine es hat sich so ein bisschen zu einer moderneren bezeichnung für
für server admins die ein bisschen über den tellerrand gucken etabliert aber eigentlich
kommt sehr eher daher so nach dem motto ein team aus entwicklern baut eine software und die
gucken an dass man die auch irgendwie betreibt aber es hat sich so ein bisschen es hat sich
verselbstständigt das ist der begriff also es hat eigentlich gar keinen sinn da groß drüber
rum zu diskutieren zum beispiel wer wer öfters mal hier reddit dephops liest da gibt es jeden
zweiten tag eine diskussion darüber dass dephops doch eigentlich gar kein beruf ist und solche
geschichten und ja es ist im prinzip egal was was man sich da so zurecht fantasiert wie es in der
theorie halt sein sollte aber in der praxis gibt es halt jobs mit der bezeichnung und dass ja das
worauf es ankommt okay tätigkeiten hatten wir schon genauso wie für die konzeption von
kombiniertes azure aks ok cloud platform primär auf azure ok passt eigentlich ganz gut was mich
persönlich abschrecken würde ist flexibles und mobiles arbeiten das ist so nach dem motto ja
max heute bist du übrigens bei hamburg im einsatz auch übrigens heute muss nach nürnberg heute muss
nach senfberg ach nee senftenberg oder nach zwigau oder was da hätte ich jetzt tatsächlich
kein bock drauf ja um verreiche fachliche und methodische training bocky 1 os team spirit
offenen tür und kommunikation auf augen gelebte vielfalt bla bla bla bla bla so zeug schreiben
sie alle ihre persönlichkeit zuverlässig gewissen aber die ok sie haben ein sehr gutes
technisches fachwissen im angestreben auf so wie gute kenntnis eigentlich kommt aber ok hier
kommt was konkretes sie beherrschen der fobs mit hohen und tools zum beispiel scrum git lab
container services so nah cube das irgendwie in java shit ist das glaube ich oder chat wer
weiß es so so nah ist das nicht so dass das neue maven für für java das neue next ach keine ahnung
ich blicke im java umfeld nicht durch dankeschön für den sub
nexus flux dass es im kubernetes umfeld ich weiß nicht ob die das hier meinen oder ob es
nicht was anderes gibt im java umfeld was ich auch flux nennt kafka salt stack warum stehen
die alle so auf salt sie bringen umgang mit terraform und man kann ein bisschen javascript
und python sie sind interessiert an cloud gut also das hier das hier geht alles in ordnung
worauf ich keinen bock hatte ist das hier hätte mich jetzt auch nicht so geschockt ja unsere
benefits mobiles arbeiten gehaltspaket erfolgsbeteiligung 37 5 ok das finde ich
nice weil dann wäre ich mit vier tage woche quasi bei 9 und bei was wäre ich dann mit
vier tages woche 30 ungefähr oder und 20,6 arbeitszeitkonten moment warum ist das ein
vorteil 30 tage urlaub ok naja so was haben wir überfliegen das mal ein bisschen ich
euro baustoff die kooperation ok auch durch fünf enger austausch mit dem
product owner und die stakeholder wird mal schön gegrillt eine runde fach informat erkenntnis
ist die icd die machen grafana prometheus craylock ok wir können auch einfach loki
nehmen wenn man schon grafana hat aber gut das hat sich vielleicht get lab cloud in fascia pap
0 auf 15 ob mich jetzt nicht
was ist das nicht pflicht nach dem neuen gesetz was denn was meinst du das damit mit zeitkonten ja
der zeit der fassung ist pflicht
hi max ich bin gerade auf stellensuche elektroniker für automatisierung
was sich mittlerweile alles für ausbildungsberufe gibt wurde leider nicht bei meiner ausbildungs bei
meinem ausbildungsbetrieb übernommen hast du einen tipp für meine warum wurdest du denn nicht
übernommen hast du ein gutes zeugnis oder hast du dich mit denen überhaupt nicht verstanden und
die wollten dich nicht mehr also was war was war der grund also weshalb wurdest du oder
oder wolltest du nicht kann ja auch sein darf man nicht vergessen also wenn du ein gutes zeugnis
hast ist auf jeden fall irgendwie wobei du hast eine ausbildung gemacht vergesst was ich gesagt
habe kann man kann man ein zeugnis schreiben für den azubi geht so was habe ich glaube ich noch
nie gesehen na gut ansonsten ja ausbildung also das das auf jeden fall ich bin ausgelernt ja
aber warum wollten die dich nicht mehr haben hatten die hast du dich mit denen nicht verstanden oder
was war der grund weil meist die meisten machen sich ja nicht die arbeit drei jahre
leute auszubilden um sie dann nicht zu übernehmen gerade in der heutigen zeit nicht ich kann dir
leider nichts gescheites raten dazu weil ich habe keine ahnung von dieser von dieser branche und ich
wüsste auch nicht was ich als fisi oder so raten sollte ich meine ok als fisi würde ich dir raten
sucht ihr halt einen bereich raus der dir gefällt ich und ich hoffe du hättest ihn in der in der
ausbildung schon gefunden und schau dass du da was findest weil wenn du in dem bereich arbeiten
kannst der dich interessiert dann wirst du auch in dem bereich immer besser und kannst weiter in
dem bereich arbeiten beziehungsweise stört dich nicht so sehr da sich mit sachen auseinanderzusetzen
weil es dir weil es der bereich ist der dir gefällt allerdings hier ich habe keine ahnung
hier präge leute übermorgen abschlussprüfung nice
das heißt wir sollten morgen mal im stream eine probeprüfung machen oder
als falls ich eine finde die öffentlich zugänglich ist also leute ihr müsst mir
keine pdf schicken ich sag's euch immer wieder weil ich habe die selbst die dinger aber du
darfst die halt nicht benutzen also wir müssen irgendwo eine öffentliche probeprüfung finden
ja haben wir sogar im stream schon gemacht und haben abgekackt weiß ich noch das richtig
verschissen wir können aufgaben abwandeln ja das könnte man machen also wenn da einer bock drauf
hat ok lasst uns mal beim experten portal gucken wir gucken jetzt noch mal ganz kurz noch ein
paar devops engineer stellen und danach könnt ihr mir danach schlagt wenn ihr wenn ihr irgendwas
sehen wollt macht man einen vorschlag im chat was wir suchen sollen oder auch jetzt schon wir
müssen ja nicht immer nach sachen für mich suchen ich suche ja grad gar nix ok fully remote
ne partially remote ist wichtig wobei ganz ehrlich ich bin ja eigentlich eher darauf aus dass ich
system administrator ok suchen wir danach alles klar kann man gleich danach machen
defsack bis auf ob alter was zum
was haben die denn mit dieser input box gemacht man
für was steht das business sucht keiner
ok iot defops engineer iot das was von patrick in ulm oh nee da gehe ich nicht mal hin ich war
ich war mal eine ganze zeit lang in ulm alter nee nee nee nee ulm gebe ich mir nicht mehr
ja vielleicht bin ich damals zu geiler tricks über den weg gelaufen und weiß es nicht nee
da habe ich keinen bock drauf genau der richtige job für mich c++ programmierer
expert devops engineer
warum sind die sachen alle auf englisch
habe ich die seite irgendwie auf englisch stehen oder so
kann man die sprache vielleicht umstellen die sind einfach einfach broken
du warst auf slash en aber
was ist das denn das ist englisch das ist female male diverse wahrscheinlich das ist
das ist quasi mvd genau das ist mvd auf englisch agila devops engineer bei parship leute nix wie
hin das ist das ist der job für uns leute
hallo
agiler devops engineer vollzeit home office möglich job oder liebe beides
wenn es darum geht die liebe zu finden kommt man an der parship group nicht vorbei
ok selbstbeweihräucherung wie immer ok also wie wir software entwickeln was uns ausmacht
wir entwickeln unsere eigenen produkte dabei ist unser einsatz von pair programming test
getriebene entwicklung code reviews und refactorings wichtig
ja ok wir vertrauen innerhalb unseres kannbaren prozesses auf autonome und
eigenverantwortliche teams agilität ist für uns nicht nur in der entwicklung der leitgedanke
das ganze unternehmen arbeitet nach agilen prinzipien das ganze unternehmen ich möchte mal
darauf hinweisen dass die grundgedanken von hinter dieser ganzen agile geschichte explizit
für software entwicklung sind nicht für ganze unternehmen die sind wirklich die leute die sich
das damals ausgedacht haben den ging es explizit steht auch mehrfach drinnen um software entwicklung
gut die sind so agil dass das überall schon agile ist sogar sogar der empfang ist agil
im platform team entwickeln und betreiben wir eine kubernetes basierte platform mit dem ziel
selbst service dienste anzubeiten und die unabhängigkeit der feature teams in
entwicklung und betrieb zu stärken meine güte ist das kompliziert geschrieben alter
das ist ja mal wie verklausuliert soll man eigentlich schreiben was man macht im platform
team entwickeln und betreiben wir eine kubernetes basierte platform mit dem ziel
selbst service dienste anzubieten und die unabhängigkeit der feature teams in
entwicklung und betrieb zu stärken meine güte ist das kompliziert geschrieben alter
hätten die nicht so was schreiben können wie sie unterstützen unsere
entwickler teams oder sowas das ist es ja im endeffekt mit ihren mit ihren tools
unterstützen sie unsere entwickler teams oder irgendwas keine ahnung aber das ist
super kompliziert geschrieben dabei gehören spezialisten aus dem
bereich qa beckern und der pops zu unserem team ok bei problem suchen wir
nach einer lösung nicht nach einem schuldigen ja das sagen sie immer bin ich
mal gespannt wie das bei meiner aktuellen firma ist wo ich wo ich jetzt
angefangen habe anfang abril wenn da mal wirklich was kaputt geht da bin ich
gespannt die haben auch gesagt die suchen ich suche nicht den schuldigen
sondern quasi löse ich bin ich mal gespannt wenn da was kaputt geht ob da
blame game gespielt wird oder oder nicht ok wen suchen sie du hast erfahrung mit
dem betrieb von hochverfügbaren web anwendung und self hosted kubernetes in
virtualisierten ich möchte an der stelle noch mal kurz betonen dass ich
der meinung bin dass selbst hauset kubernetes meistens nicht sinnvoll ist
weil da enorm viel dazu gehört einen
gut lauf wegen kubernetes cluster auf die beine zu stellen das macht natürlich
sinn wenn man sagt ok wir dürfen aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht in die
cloud oder wir dürfen aus irgendwelchen gründen das nicht uns einkaufen warum
auch immer man das sagen sollte aber ok kann ja sein und dann braucht man aber
wirklich leute die ahnung davon haben also kubernetes selbst betreiben ist
nicht ohne kubernetes sieht auf den ersten blick noch überschaubar und simpel
aus wenn man so das erste das erste tutorial gemacht hat denkt man sich ja
ist ja nichts dabei machst mal ein bisschen den deployment machst mal hier
ein bisschen was ein service mal notbalancer und dann geht das auch schon
aber kubernetes ist ein so das ökosystem drumherum das ist so breites
und und reichhaltiges thema und es spornt jeden tag ein neues kubernetes
cloud projekt was dann innerhalb von zwei wochen 5000 github sterne hat das
ist tatsächlich nicht einfach zumal zumal man hat auch vieles selbst machen
muss ja du musst dir zum beispiel gedanken machen wie wie machst du das
mit deinen load balancer in kubernetes nimmst du sowas wie metal lb oder sowas also sprich
die cloud anbieter unterstützen es ja normalerweise du definierst einfach
dein service und es funktioniert ja du musst alles selbst machen du musst
load balancer selbst machen du musst ingress geschichten selbst machen du
musst monitoring sachen sehr du musst quasi alles selbst machen das ist ein sehr komplexes
themengebiet ja also ich würde sagen wer kubernetes selbst hostet ist da schon mutig
oder ist sehr zuversichtlich in seiner eigenen skills ja das ist durchaus das kann ich mir
tatsächlich vorstellen dass es günstiger ist eigene sachen zu betreiben cloud muss
nicht zwangsläufig billig sein das sage ich ja auch öfters also gerade in der alten firma
wo ich war haben sie sich auch maßlos verkalkuliert am anfang so nach dem oder
das wird doch wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen billiger als ich weg bin haben sie irgendwas
im siebenstelligen bereich monatlich monatlich im siebenstelligen bereich cloudkosten gehabt
also es war über kann ich sagen mal ein bisschen über zwei millionen glaube ich cloudkosten im
monat und das problem ist gar nicht so sehr damit dass es das ist so die kostenfrage selbst wenn
es billiger ist ist halt die frage ob man sich das ob man sich das selbst zumuten will man
bezahlt halt bei der cloud halt oftmals die expertise und sowieso ease of use bezahlt man
auch wenn es teurer ist unterm strich naja gut wenn die könniger haben wollen was sie wollen sie
suchen alle leute du verfügst über do you need komponiert das punkt kommen no das ist
eine geile seite jetzt da noch irgendwie weiter oder es ist der einzige seiten hin halt
ok du verfügst über wissen aber der terraform puppet war damit die old school der old school
hammer rausgeholt hier puppet ich verfüge tatsächlich über puppet erfahrungen weil
wir das in der alten firma recht recht ausführlich benutzt haben. du strebst nach einem hohen grad an
automatisierung hast du nie die programmierkenntnisse. es steht enorm wenig drin was sie eigentlich machen
und was sie eigentlich haben wollen muss ich jetzt mal sagen weil ein bisschen kubernetes
ein bisschen terraform ein bisschen linux ist jetzt nicht so kann ich mir jetzt nicht so viel
reiben drauf machen. was warum braucht man kubernetes nicht? baut man appservice bei
azure oder... ich glaube mal dass die seite darauf anspielt dass man nicht für jeden mist
kubernetes braucht. also so nach dem motto starte kleine kleine web anwendung mit sqlite
brauche ich kein kubernetes für. ja das habe ich schon gesehen aber insgesamt ist es ein
bisschen wenig was sie an technologien einsetzen oder? ich meine terraform und linux das sollte
eigentlich komplett klar sein ja ansonsten ist halt ich meine gerade kubernetes ist so ein
großes felt da könnte man durchaus die ein oder anderen sachen droppen von dem was man was man
benutzt oder vielleicht auch was sie für als als continuous integration platform verwenden
war es auch immer dass man ein bisschen ahnung hat was das sache ist
working for love liebe geht durch den magen early birds starten ihren tag bei uns mit einem
guten frühstück mit oh leute da bin ich dabei ist das kostenlos ist das kostenlos also ob ich
für love werke oder nicht interessiert mich nicht aber jeden tag kostenlos essen zum früh das fände
ich schon mal nicht verkehrt da bin da bin ich dabei
finde das aber gar nicht so schlecht die anzeige muss ich sagen das ist das ist das ist zwar immer
noch ein bisschen nur nach 15 aber ich finde es durchaus es ist modern ich muss sagen wie soll
ich sagen es ist modern aber nicht auf auf hip gemacht geschrieben das ist schon ok ich würde
mich wahrscheinlich nicht dort bewerben aber also ich suche eh keinen job gerade aber es ist
durchaus klingt doch ganz ok ok wir feiern zweimal jährlich im sommer und winter mit oh
gott hört mir bloß auf leute warum denkt jeder dass das geil ist nach der arbeit da noch rum zu
hängen ich mache nach der arbeit gehe ich heim macht der katz was zu essen oder spiel
ein bisschen mit der katz mach streamer machen youtube video spiel irgendwas wir gucken uns
zusammen irgendwas hier auf twitch an ich ich laber mit meinem five head chat das ist mir
alle mal lieber als weiter auf der arbeit rum zu hängen und und legendäre parties zu machen
zusätzlich gibt es monatlich ein büro afterwork am mittwoch ja gut schön ohne mich also ich bin
eh nicht da aber nee nee nee nee auch was für dinger kickertisch na ok das weiß ich auch
fashion victims kommen mit diversen shopping eine regelmäßige überprüfung deiner seestärke
in der aktuellen situation arbeiten wir größtenteils von zu hause und leben unsere
firmenkultur remote via teams das klappt super wir freuen uns aber auch schon darauf wieder
regelmäßig in unsere büros zurückzukehren da geht schon los da geht schon los warum ich da
kein bock drauf hätte dann erwarten dich homeoffice regel und die auf anforderungen
bedürfnisse der einzelnen fachbereiche und das heißt im prinzip es gibt wahrscheinlich
dann auch noch ein tag die woche homeoffice oder sowas aber so wie das geschrieben ist ganz ehrlich
so wie das geschrieben ist wollen die bestimmt niemand der sagt ich will 80 prozent oder 90
prozent homeoffice machen so ein tag die woche ein tag alle 14 tage sowas nach dem motto da haben
die bestimmt kein bock drauf wir das love team arbeiten für die liebe und kennen weder alter
noch geschlecht herkunft noch hautfarbe sexuelle noch religiöse orientierung jetzt wollen sie
es aber wissen hier vielmehr sind wir davon überzeugt dass gelebte chancengleichheit zu
mehr vielfalten damit zu besseren arbeitsergebnissen wird deshalb zählen für uns seine persönlichkeit
an qualifikation so das sollte eigentlich meine ansicht nach selbstverständlich sein ohne dass
man das ewig ausbreiten muss es zählen persönlichkeit und qualifikation ist letztendlich geht es ja hier
um business und um geld verdienen und ums arbeiten um nicht und nicht irgendwie irgendwelche quoten
oder sowas ok ja ich mein nicht direkt mein fall aber warum nicht ja war doch war doch ganz in
ordnung wir hatten auch noch keine so richtige kack stellenanzeige was haben die m die suchen
ich will ich will irgendeine stellenanzeige wenigstens noch mal finden die so richtig
müll ist der tomagd sap cloud alle 10 minuten bewirbt sich eine erfolgreiche aus einer
erfolgreiche bewerbung ja das müssten die tatsächlich als sprach haben die seite ist
enorm schnell gerade muss ich sagen hyper hyper speed website der tomagd alles klar
oder oder tum wie das manche aussprechen aussprechen das archiv ist dauernd keck
was ist da denn los? also die suchen jemand, devops engineer, sap cloud, javascript frontend
developer ok das ist schon mal eine sehr merkwürdige mischung also suchen sie jetzt
den devops engineer für die sap cloud was auch immer das bedeuten soll oder suchen sie
ein javascript frontend developer. das sind ja nur wirklich sehr unterschiedliche. suchen
sie vielleicht einen frontend developer für sap? suchen sie vielleicht einen frontend developer
der sap uis machen kann oder sowas? kann das vielleicht der hintergrund sein? ja das frontend
vielleicht auf ja ich hab keine ahnung von sap. tomac gehört zur reeve doch das wusste
ich tatsächlich das wusste ich. und bei uns stehst du im vordergrund und ein ganzes team
denn respekt gegenseitig wertschätzung und unterstützungen für uns als wichtigste egal
in welcher position über uns arbeitest. okay nice. wir arbeiten mit zahlreichen scrum teams nach
safe. exzellent. klarer scrum prozess mit sprints sprint plannings daily sprint review und retrospektive
ja gut so macht man das ja die frage ist nur ob dies also man es gibt ja viele unternehmen die sagen
gerne dass sie das machen nur weil es einen klaren scrum prozess gibt heißt es auch lange
nicht dass sie das so richtig machen und nur weil sie sprints haben sprint plannings reviews und
dailies ohne retrospektiv weiß auch nicht dass das alles richtig gemacht wird ja zum beispiel wenn
ich dann solche sachen sehe wie das scrum master ist gleichzeitig der der projekt verantwortliche
da denkt man sich so ein moment das passt nicht so ganz zusammen ja anfried dankeschön für den
sub sorry leute falls ich irgendjemand übersehen habe ich gucke mal kurz ob ich wieder leute
übersehen danke für den sub hatte ich glaube ich schon egal kann ich oft genug sagen also deine
aufgaben so mal gucken was das tohmarkt haben will weiß ja nicht toh ist es ist es tohbaumarkt
ist das ein bisschen agile implementierung von s4 hana als leuchtturmprojekt mit sap steht
bei uns im focus ok da hätte ich überhaupt keinen bock drauf sap ui 5 ok wie sieht das aus
ok es sieht immer noch kacke aus aber nicht mal ganz so scheiße wie früher
deine aufgaben also ok ich habe doch recht gehabt die suchen ein java script entwickler
für pap frontends da hätte ich ja sowas von kein bock drauf alter
ich glaube aber da verdient man richtig asche mit
ich glaube da verdient man richtig geld mit als sap als sap kenner
das mache ich mal zu da ist nix hier
was wollen die hier denn die die sehen schon richtig modern und agil und hip aus und die
lachen und sind fröhlich bei ihrem job das erwarte dich der fob
hä du bist verantwortlich für den second level support ja was denn jetzt als der fob
engine übernimmst du den den aufbau und weiterentwicklung von individuellen
plattform auf basis ja ok
je nachdem was sie darunter verstehen du betreust und überwachst die cloudbasierte infrastruktur
ja deine aufgaben umfassen im betrieb die service überwachen das stück gibt es irgendwas was ich
nicht mache du arbeitest bei der erstellung von technischen konzepten und pflege in der
dokumentation muss nur stütze die einrichtung ist verantwortlich für den second level support
in die aufrechnung haltung des betriebes alter jetzt ja mal gut ist aber gut man die wollen aber
auch alles oder halbe it abteilung in einer person wieder du bist quasi software entwickler
der fox engineer für ja monitoring automatisierung du machst second level support und doku und
gleichzeitig bist du auch noch verantwortlich für den second level support so eine art teamleiter
oder sowas wahrscheinlich dann und dann machst du auch noch kompletten betrieb
monitoring und störungs management auch noch alles klar nice
nice ok für 300k im jahr mache ich das ich meine es sind vier jobs auf einmal
also das ist ja wirklich schon
dein studium im bereich informatik hast du erfolgreich abgeschlossen du verfügst über
einen vergleichbare qual also wenn sie wenn eine ausbildung reicht dann schreibt ausbildung
hin weil ganz ehrlich dafür brauchst du jemand mit praxiserfahrung da brauchst du jemand der
einige der wirklich schon also wenn das wirklich in irgendeiner position da brauchst du keine frisch
studiert hat da geht ja komplett unter bei sowas und auch keine frisch ausgelernt hast du brauchst
also also vor allem wenn das hier keine senior stelle ist dann weiß ich auch nicht was du musst
ja alles machen also du machst administration entwicklung da kennst du dich mit java spring
boot mysql abklatsch und gitlab aus dann hast du noch docker kubernetes mongo db linux und jms
erfahrung ich weiß nicht was jm ist irgendwas java mäßiges java message service alles klar
du lernst gerne neues stellst den in frage blablabla ein persönliches buddy programm also ich
bevorzuge es mir aus also ich bevorzuge es mir auszusuchen wer meine buddies sind und nicht dass
ich die zugewiesen bekomme da frage ich mich was sie hierfür bezahlen ich meine das ist wieder
ob obviously eine stellenanzeige wo der personal mensch der das geschrieben hat keine ahnung hatte
von dem was er da schreibt und vielleicht suchen die auch wirklich drei verschiedene jobs in der
hoffnung dass sie einen damit besetzen können
ich glaube 26 tage im jahr sind gesetzlich vorgeschrieben bin mir nicht ganz sicher
aber 30 tag jetzt eigentlich standard
hast du eigentlich erfahrung mit unreal
nee zumal unreal auch viel c++ ist und da habe ich ja noch weniger bock drauf
fach trainings persönliches coaching für die relevanten job skills
individuelle persönliche innerhalb der 7p karrierewelt was
ich verstehe die coachen nicht quasi selbst
guck mal hier das ist bestimmt das party programm
aber das sind doch stockfotos oder
das sind doch garantiert stockfotos das sind doch nicht wirklich leute von denen
ich suche keinen neuen arbeitgeber nein nein nein nein nein nein leute was links unten
was meinst du
ich weiß nicht wie wir das kommando haben aber ich suche keinen neuen job das bild oben das hier ja
das ist 100 pro in stockfoto was soll das sonst sein das ist garantiert in stockfoto
viel gut atmosphäre regelmäßige mit warum warum denken alle personalabteilung IT le haben bock
auf regelmäßige mitarbeiter und team events ich wette mit euch 80 prozent der IT le haben
kein bock auf den graben die wollen im keller vor ihrem computer sitzen ok vielleicht ab und
so zu ein bisschen was anderes machen aber ok ich gehe sogar noch weiter 80 prozent der normalen
leute die arbeiten gehen wollen auf die arbeit gehen und dann heim gehen und erstmal nichts
mehr mit der arbeit zu tun haben und umso besser es der arbeitgeber macht beziehungsweise umso
angenehmer es dort ist umso mehr sind die leute auch bereit abends mal aufs handy zu gucken und
sowas teamevents zur arbeitszeit sind vollkommen ok ich bezweifle dass die teamevents zu normalen
arbeitszeiten stattfinden das ist dann eher sowas wie ah heute ist schon mal um 16 uhr
schluss weil wir haben ja 16 uhr 30 bis 18 uhr 30 heute das team event sowas in der richtung ist
das eher die werden doch bezahlt wenn sie nicht bezahlt werden würde ich da nicht hingehen wobei
das kann ich tatsächlich so nicht ausschließen es kommt auf die teamevents an ja also wenn das
was ist mit leuten auf die ich bock habe ab und zu mal optional habe ich da keine schmerz da will
ich sagen komm ich auch ab und zu mal mit vielleicht aber so diese diese jeder ist doof
der absagt ne da hätte ich kein bock drauf bei uns dort wo ich früher gearbeitet habe war das
so bei der weihnachtsfeier das haben sie die letzten jahre über dann ein bisschen entschärft
du konntest dich zu an zu du es kam es kam eine meldung es findet bald wieder unsere weihnachtsfeier
statt so und dann wurde von dir erwartet egal ob du hinkommen willst oder nicht dass du ein
dokument ausfüllt ist jeder hat per mail einen link bekommen zu einem formular was man sich
damals noch ausdrucken sollte und unterschrieben zurückschicken sollte dann und dieses formular
sah folgendermaßen aus ja war für sich weihnachtsfeier am 20.12. ich nehme teil
und bringe irgendwie noch keine ahnung meine frau mit oder sowas ok und dann gab es noch ein
zweites fällt ich nehme nicht teil und dann stand dahinter weil also du konntest quasi nur an
an ankreuzen ich nehme teil oder ich nehme nicht teil weil und sie wollten tatsächlich dass die
leute dann da irgendwas hinschreiben ich habe da nie was hingeschrieben in den ganzen jahren wo
ich da war habe ich nie was hingeschrieben ich habe oftmals auch gar nicht abgesagt genau weil
dort weil stand gebe es einfach die möglichkeit online in ihrem portal zu sagen ich nehme nicht
teil dass die besser planen können hätte ich das gemacht aber dieses ich nehme nicht teil weil das
ist schon sehr frech oder also ich nehme nicht teil weil muss es muss ich überhaupt nicht begründen
naja ich ich ich habe es ja geschafft bei meinem letzten arbeitgeber ich war über zehn jahre da
leute stellt euch das mal vor über zehn jahre und ich war nicht einmal auf der weihnachtsfeier nicht
einmal und um ein zehnjahres jubiläumsessen habe ich mich auch erfolgreich gedrückt
regelmäßige mittag ok bony job rad und firmen hat mich jetzt nicht so geschockt ok was haben
die hier am start sie betreuen jetzt geht's los leute def sack ops prozesse sie verantworten den
operations teil in einer def sack ob moment was also das ist schon wieder so kompliziert geschrieben
dass ich überhaupt nicht weiß was die vor mir wollen sie verantworten den operations teil in
einer def sack ops organisation im umfeld von container technologie und orchestrierung mit
kubernetes und schreibt es halt noch komplizierter mann schreibt es please noch komplizierter sie
sind für installationen betrieb und überwachung der software entwicklungsplattform sowie
dokumentation leute die haben noch nicht verstanden dass wir prinzipiell nichts verkehrt machen und
dementsprechend auch nichts dokumentieren müssen weil wenn man keine fehler macht dann geht es
logischerweise auch immer und geht nicht kaputt und dementsprechend muss man es auch nicht
dokumentieren es ist halt wie es hier enorme zeit ersparen ist sie aber in einem global agierenden
internationalen team also nicht agil
suzé rancher monka es zwei kombinationen auf die ich ja überhaupt kein bock hätte suzé und rancher
und sie sind belastbar wenn das schon immer so oft offensiv in so stellenanzeigen drin steht
ich weiß ich finde es ist immer kein gutes kein gutes zeichen ja
ist rennscher so schlimm nee ist es nicht
abwechselt wie lange ist die anzeige schon drin auch vor zwei tagen leute also wenn
die nicht super krasses gehalt bezahlen fürchte ich werden die nix finden die stellenanzeige ist
viel zu viel zu 0815 und so ein paar dinge würden mich jetzt nicht so nicht so schocken
ehrlich gesagt du musst heute schon gucken dass ein bisschen raussticht wenn du wenn du
bewerbung haben willst gerade wenn du halt nicht die leute einfach zuscheißen kannst mit geld
oder halt so einen großen namen hast dass die leute dir die bude einrennen sie bringen sie
haben sie können sie verfügen sie sind sie sind ein geborener team player mwd
ok ich gette ja warum man das hier im titel schreibt aber was soll mir das mwd an dieser
stelle sagen dass mein team sich aus männlich weiblich divers zusammensetzen kann dass player
selbstverständlich auch alle anderen einschließt oder ist mir in dem fall zum lesen lieber als ein
geborener team player innen abwechslungsreiches nee das hat mir jetzt nicht sonderlich angesprochen
ehrlich gesagt was ist denn was ist hier los warum geht das nicht
exeter best buddy for one and only
ok das macht man installiere konfigurat ministriere unsere systemwirtschaft zum
beispiel zum beispiel im cloud umfeld ja und nicht zum beispiel wo sonst noch
setze systemarchitektur gemäß und sie blablabla optimieren sie ok ja das würde ich erwarten
dabei aber sehr nur nach 15 alles dm alles was wollen die haben java anwendungen die an die
die ganzen anzeigen sind so furchtbar 08 15 da bewirbt sich doch aktuell gar keiner gar keiner
drauf ernsthaft ich hätte übrigens auch mich im leben nicht auf die auf die ursprüngliche anzeige
beworben obwohl die sehr gut gepasst hat die war aber halt auch sehr 08 15 so super business
mäßig geschrieben ja also von den anforderungen hat wirklich super gepasst aber die war nicht
irgendwie so anscheinend nicht irgendwie großartig ansprechend geschrieben also ich
hätte mich dort wo ich jetzt angefangen habe auch nicht darauf beworben hätte ich die stellen
anzeige gesehen es war einzig und allein nur weil mich jemand angeschrieben hat den ich schon kannte
ja und weil ich weg wollte und die gut bezahlen klar das war dann aber erstmal das zweite weil
erstmal muss ich mich überhaupt noch bewerben. Warum stehen bei den stellenanzeigen eigentlich
nie grobe Gehaltsangaben? Das finde ich auch doof, ganz ehrlich das finde ich richtig bescheuert,
weil man könnte sich damit tatsächlich aus der Masse gut herausstellen, sofern man denn
was zu bieten hat. Also wenn man natürlich jetzt hofft, so wie hier der Nico schreibt,
dass die Leute sich darauf bewerben und so für einen Appel und einen richtig guten Mitarbeiter
bekommen, okay vielleicht spekulieren die darauf, aber ist das wirklich ein Unternehmen,
was auch plant, Geld in die Hand zu nehmen, um einen guten Mitarbeiter zu bekommen? Ohne
Mist, die könnten tatsächlich sich sehr gut positionieren, wenn man zumindest mal so eine
grobe Gehaltsrange hinschreiben würde. Weil ganz im Ernst, ich muss mich doch gar nicht bewerben,
selbst wenn mir die Anzeige super gefällt, aber wenn ich weiß, die bezahlen 40k im Jahr,
dann bewerbe ich mich da erst gar nicht. Genau, ja, sehe ich auch so. Ja, das würde ich so pauschal
gar nicht mal sagen. Ich weiß, wie schwer ich mich immer tue, da konkrete Zahlen zu nennen und
da jetzt was Konkretes mir aus dem Finger zu saugen. Ja, also ich glaube, Leute, die jetzt schon eine
Weile in der Branche tätig sind, die haben schon eine ganz gute Vorstellung, was so ungefähr so
Gehaltsniveau drumherum ist in ihrer Branche, in ihrer Region. Einige trauen sich vielleicht
nicht zu sagen, manche andere denken, das ist ja unverschämt viel oder was auch immer ist es,
man muss auch sagen im Vergleich, kann man dann denke ich nicht oft genug sagen, im Vergleich zu
anderen Jobs ist das tatsächlich unverschämt viel, was ich verdiene, aber soll ich sagen,
ich nehme es nicht, weil ich auch mit weniger auskomme, also das wäre ja ultra bescheuert.
Ich meine, ernsthaft, wenn euer Chef zu euch kommt und sagt, ihr Kollege, du kriegst jetzt 10k mehr
im Jahr, dann werdet ihr auch nicht sagen, ach, ich brauche das nicht. Gibt es mal lieber jemand
anderem. Ist halt so ein bisschen Anfrage und Nachfrage, also viele in der IT, da will ich mich
nicht ausschließen, verdienen unverschämt viel im Vergleich zu dem, was beispielsweise ein
Krankenpfleger verdient, ist so. Ja, das ist wirklich eine gute Idee. Also wenn man mit Kollegen
über das Gehalt reden kann, würde ich das auf jeden Fall machen, es gibt ja welche, die sind so
super, so Geheimniskremer mäßig unterwegs und nach dem Motto, ah nee, da sage ich jetzt nichts,
oder? Das hört man hier nicht gerne, wenn darüber gesprochen wird, also scheiß drauf,
ob das gerne gehört wird oder nicht. Man, das ist nicht verboten und außerdem ist es für alle
Beteiligte unterm Strich nur gut. Okay, vielleicht für den Arbeitgeber nicht, weil er ein bisschen
mehr bezahlen muss, weil es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll zu wissen, wieso das, nennen wir es mal,
das Gehaltsgefüge ist. Und wenn ihr jemanden habt bei euch, der das gleiche macht wie ihr und irgendwie
nur 60 Prozent davon bekommt, dann ist es doch gut, wenn er das erfährt. Oder umgedreht, wenn ihr das
seid, das ist doch gut, dass man das erfährt. Da kann man dann sagen, Jungs, was ist denn bei
euch hier los? Und da wisst ihr auch, dass da durchaus, dass da durchaus was geht. Also es
ist übrigens auch überhaupt kein Problem, darüber zu reden. Das ist gesetzlich nicht
verboten. Es gibt nur ganz seltene Fälle, wo das verboten ist. Natürlich kenne ich mich rechtlich
nicht gut aus, aber ich habe mich da schon ein paar Mal drüber belesen. Es gibt Jobs, wo quasi
das Gehalt unmittelbar was mit der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit des Arbeitgebers zu tun hat. Mir fällt jetzt gar
kein Beispiel ein. Da darf man das untersagen, aber das ist bei 90% der Leute oder bei 95% der Leute
nicht der Fall. Naja, besser als sich da zu bewerben. Du hast ganz viele Bewerber, die
die dann am Ende... Also, bestes Negativbeispiel dafür ist immer ein bisschen Happy Music hier.
Bestes Beispiel ist von einem Ex-Arbeitskollege, wo ich euch erzählt habe. Der hat sich beworben
bei einer Firma, die haben geschrieben, Gehaltsspanne, der hat sich als Senior Admin oder sowas in der
Richtung beworben. Das wäre explizit eine Senior-Stelle ausgeschrieben. So, hat sich beworben,
da stand irgendwas, Gehaltsspanne 95 bis 105.000 Euro. Hat er sich darauf beworben, weil das mit
Gehaltsspanne drin stand. Und, ne, sorry, es war nicht mal Senior Admin, es war Senior Specialist,
irgendwas. Also auch was wurde angemessen dafür erschienen, ja. So hat sich da beworben. Der hat
zwei, drei Bewerbungsrunden gemacht. Telefon-Interview. Dann hat er mit denen zusammen
irgendwelche Support-Fälle durchgespielt, wie er das handhaben würde. Dann war er,
glaube ich, vor Ort noch mal. Und am Ende, als es dann darum ging, Jungs hier, Butter bei
die Fische unterschreiben, haben sie zu ihm gesagt, ach, übrigens, die Stelle ist jetzt
doch nur mit 75k bezahlt. Und da hat er gesagt, was? Wir haben da doch mehrfach drüber geredet? Die
Stelle ist ausgeschrieben mit 95-105k. Was? Hä? Ich verstehe die Welt nicht mehr. Wollt ihr mich
veräppeln? Und da haben die dann gesagt, ja, in der Budgetplanung war leider kein Platz mehr für
eine Senior-Stelle. Jetzt ist es nur eine normale. Hä? Ihr könnt doch nicht einfach Senior-Specialist
was auch immer ausschreiben. Und am Ende, wenn ihr einen Bewerber habt, der sagt, okay, ich mach
das, sagen, ach, das ist jetzt übrigens keine Senior-Stelle mehr. Ups. Es sind jetzt 30.000 Euro im
Jahr weniger. Ups. Ja, aber wir sind doch so dicke jetzt. Du machst das doch sicherlich trotzdem.
Und ich denke mir so, was denken die sich dabei? Denken die ernsthaft? Da sagt dann jemand, oh ja,
das hat mir so gut gefallen. Ihr habt mich schon beschissen, bevor ich überhaupt angefangen hab
bei euch. Ja, das ist eine super Grundlage. Hier fange ich jetzt an. Du wirst schon beschissen,
bevor du angefangen hast. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, diese Taktik,
die die Firma, das Unternehmen da gefahren hat. Weißt du, ob er trotzdem unterschrieben hat? Nein,
der hat nicht unterschrieben. Der arbeitet jetzt bei mir und verdient ungefähr das gleiche wie
ich. Also insofern. Das war wirklich ein richtiger Dickmove von denen. Das ist der,
der mit mir gewechselt ist. Ja.
Ja, aber wenn du älter bist, hattest du ja die Jahre vorher schon Möglichkeiten. Also ich gehe
nicht davon aus, dass ich die nächsten paar Jahre wieder so einen krassen Gehaltsprung mache,
wie die letzten paar Jahre. Aber ich meine, die letzten paar Jahre war ja schon, ich habe,
ich habe zweimal mehr Geld gekriegt auf der alten Arbeit, jetzt gewechselt und kriegt noch
mal mehr Geld. Also das ist unterm Strich ja schon ganz nice. Ich glaube nicht, dass ich das die
nächsten paar Jahre auch wieder haben werde. Allerdings in Anbetracht der Inflation und
sonstigen Sachen wird es zumindest in Zahlen denke ich mal einen ordentlichen Schritt geben.
Natürlich macht es dann unterm Strich halt zwar in Zahlen mehr, aber praktisch nicht mehr. Aber
wenn es einfach nur ungefähr gleich bleibt kaufkraft technisch, bin ich mehr als zufrieden.
Also ganz im Ernst, ich kann mich da nicht beschweren. Also ich sage mal so ab dem
punkt wo man sechs stellig verdient ist es doch egal wie viel mehr es ist oder letztendlich
wozu ich meine ich nehme immer mehr wenn es geht und ich werde es auch garantiert nicht
unter wert machen in zukunft ja wenn ich sehe dass es drumherum deutlich mehr gibt aber es
ist jetzt nicht wirklich so dass ich sagen will ja das muss unbedingt sein
und ich meine ich bin jetzt fast 39 siebenstellig muss das ziel ein jahr klar als krasser karriere
crying a high performer unter der million im monat im jahr ist natürlich nix verständlich
aber mir reicht das auch in der nummer drunter digit weniger
nicht jeder kein haus das kommt ja noch dabei aber dann schon aus dem gesichtspunkt muss ich
mir wenig gedanken machen genug kohle zweiter job noch mit twitch youtube und sonstigen sachen wenn
ich keinen bopp mehr drauf hab ein haus ich muss keine miete bezahlen gut das haus ist auch nicht
umsonst ja also insofern also finanziell mache ich mir wirklich keine gedanken das ist eine
sache die wirklich beruhigend ist man kann man kann wirklich sagen geld an alleine macht nicht
glücklich aber man hat viel weniger probleme oder weniger sachen und wie man sich gedanken
machen muss ja glücklich alleine wirst du davon nicht ja was weiß ich du kannst so viel verdienen
wie du willst das macht deine oma nicht mehr lebendig oder sowas setke aber ich heute morgen
erst wieder ich will keine ich will jetzt keine setke themen ansprechen heute die leute zu triggern
ich wohne ja es bin nur ich habe ich morgen wieder dran gedacht dort wo jetzt mein badezimmer ist
war früher die küche hier und da habe ich total oft als ich klein war mit der oma gehockt mit
der oma mit meiner oma ja und er kann sie noch so viel verdienen er bringt die oma nicht wieder
aber man hat trotzdem weniger sorgen und probleme mit ein bisschen kohle es ist einfach so glücklich
machen alleine tut sicherlich nicht aber muss ich um weniger gedanken machen bist du privat
krankenversichert nein bin ich nicht aber ich also ich bin ernsthaft überlegen ob ich das machen
sollte weil vor 40 ist ein guter zeitpunkt und es ist halt im prinzip ist eine krankenversicherung
eine wette auf die zukunft wenn man so will ja ob sich das rechnet oder nicht wenn du wettest
dass du immer gesund sein wirst und ja vielleicht mal schwer krank wirst und dann gleich abkratzt
brauchst du es nicht wenn du denkst hey vielleicht ist es in zukunft dann doch
nicht so nicht so verkehrt und wenn man bisschen krank ist dann ist es nice ja also ich bin
ernsthaft überlegen das zu machen ich meine ich bin mittlerweile eine ganze ecke über dieser grenze
ich glaube was war die bemessungsgrenze dieses jahr 65k oder irgendwie sowas mr. amek für den
sub und ich bin wirklich ernsthaft überlegen es ist halt teuer als fack ich bezahle irgendwie
400 euro im monat oder sowas dann irgendwie in dem dreh ich habe also mit so einem calculator
das ausgerechnet also es ist schon nicht ohne auf der anderen seite kriegt man auch sehr viel
für die gesetzliche versicherung abgezogen und den arbeitgeberanteil bezahlt er ja weiterhin
also insofern ist es wahrscheinlich trotzdem teurer gerade wenn man den vertrag sinnigerweise so
abschließt dass es nicht ultra teuer wird im alter doch lohnt sich noch ich habe letztens mal
ein guide gelesen die geschrieben hat also bis spätestens 45 sollte man es gemacht haben
im arbeitsvertrag steht selbst wenn das im arbeitsvertrag steht dass du nicht über
geld reden darfst ist das zu 95 prozent erfällen nicht gültig deswegen gibt es auch kaum noch
arbeitsverträge würde ich jetzt mal so sagen wo das wirklich drinne steht also 35 bis 38k pro
jahr sollte wirklich das minimum sein auch nach der ausbildung ich kann euch sagen ich habe damals
ja und ich habe eine ausbildung 2007 gemacht ich habe damals 33,5k im jahr verdient damals nach
der ausbildung so und das müsste jetzt eigentlich mal angepasst schon eher was um 40 sein aber
hier drunter würde ich auf gar keinen fall anfangen ja so muss es sein
ich würde generell nicht im monat sagen ich würde immer über jahresgehalt reden das ist einfach
klarer letztendlich um was es geht
hattest du echt wo denn schick noch mal schick jetzt noch mal ich bin sich
random win
schick noch mal
wie sieht es mit weiblicher bekleidung aus dann könnte ich wohl kaum da könnte ich wohl
kaum den ganzen tag von der arbeit vom rechner sitzen abends vom rechner sitzen und streamen
und zwischenzeitlich am wochenende vom rechner sitzen und mir irgendwelche neuen it themen angucken
also wenn ich irgendwie eine frau hätte die hier wohnt oder sonst was in der richtung gar
vielleicht verheiratet wäre ich habe überhaupt keine lust drauf habe aber man weiß ja nie was
sich da in zukunft man kann es ja nicht erahnen da würde ich aber wohl kaum so viel vom rechner
sitzen die will ja dann auch ein bisschen was von mir haben ja also wie gesagt ich denke mal
dass das so um 40k durchaus durchaus in ordnung ist achso nach dem studium ja dann vielleicht
dann vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen mehr also unter 40k ist vielleicht also wie gesagt ich
habe damals 33,5 nach der ausbildung verdient und das ist halt schon 2000 das hat schon ganz
schon lange her also unter 40k sollte eigentlich nichts sein ich kann zu studium gehälter nicht
sagen aber klingt doch erst mal ganz ok hast du schon eine skill ist in einem video ja in
dem video nicht ne ne ja verstehe ich lange bahnfahrten sind für den arsch
ne also heiraten ist glaube ich so ziemlich das beschissenste was ich mir vorstellen
können da habe ich absolut kein bock drauf also null ich habe schon keine lust auf zusammenwohnen
ehrlich gesagt aber heiraten erst recht ne wirklich nicht ja gut gibt es gibt es so und
also gegen eine freundin wo man am wochenende mal was macht oder sich ein paar mal in der
woche sieht jeder in einer eigenen wohnung nichts einzuwenden hätte ich auch mal wieder
nichts dagegen ja aber gut wo soll ich jemand kennenlernen gerade ist nicht so einfach im
zug wahrscheinlich am besten noch her dass das bahn grill aber sie bescheuert ich mich
immer anstelle bei den sachen habe ich euch ja schon ein paar mal erzählt falls sich noch
jemand anders an das weihnachtsgrill erinnert oder an was habe ich euch sonst noch erzählt
wahrscheinlich habe ich euch alle möglichen sachen schon erzählt keine ahnung ich stelle
mich bei sowas ja auch immer äußerst unfähig an weil ich so mit sozialen sachen immer nicht
gut klarkomme ja also ich bin immer furchtbar motivationslos was zwischenmenschliche sachen
angeht also selbst wenn sich an wenn sich nur anzeichnet dass da was gehen könnte mache ich
einfach nix also es ist sobald ich mich um zwischenmenschliche sachen kümmern muss
habe ich instant kein bock und dementsprechend wenn man das nicht mal ein bisschen weiter verfolgt
kann er auch nichts rauskommen da kann ich nichts zu sagen das glaube ich dir sofort mit frau
erstmal wieder auf ein festival und danach abhauen ja das ist das problem leute so bin ich mir werden
mir werden soziale sachen und zwischenmenschliche sachen schnell zu viel dieses vom festival abhauen
und die im wald sitzen lassen das ist so typischer typischer kram also sobald es darum geht dass man
ein bisschen einsatz zeigen muss was zwischenmenschliche sachen angeht höre ich instant auf das weiter zu
verfolgen ja es ist sogar so selbst wenn ich in der bahn sitze ja und ein bisschen rumgucke
ja und manchmal kommt es ja durchaus vor dass dann irgendwie noch ein paar plätze weiter eine
sitzt so guckt sich da mal so aus dem augenwinkel an kurz kurz blick kontakt und man merkt ja schon
ok das auch schon zweimal her geguckt und sobald ich merke ok da könnte man eventuell auch nur
entfernt daran denken vielleicht mal irgendwas zu machen gucke ich lieber die ganze fahrt in die
andere richtung will meine ruhe haben ich hasse zwischenmenschliche sachen ich kann mich da immer
ultra schwer dazu überwinden inzwischen menschliche ja sachen zu engagen ist es schwierig
schwierig zu beschreiben ja das war was machst du denn jetzt wenn dann dann im zweifelsfall
es war super unangenehm ich kann mich noch dran erinnern ich habe mal schon ein paar jahre her
es war super unangenehm da hat im zug eine neben mir gehockt und mit der habe ich dann ein bisschen
ein bisschen angefangen small talk das ist halt so zufällig zufällig so ergeben ja damals das war
glaube ich dass wir überlegen ich kriegste ich kriegste gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen ich
glaube ich habe ihr ihr sportzeug oben in die in diese leiste vom vom zug gestellt ja die saß
da schon genau ja genau so war die saß da schon und der ganze zug war voll und die hat halt
sport kram oder was das war ein großes großes gepäckstück taschen kram ich vermute mal so eine
englische sporttasche stehen gehabt habe ich gesagt wie sieht es denn da aus kann ich da noch
irgendwelche meins ja hier ist aber es ist voll habe ich gesagt ja ich kann das da oben ich kann
das halt oben hoch stellen wenn sie will ja und es meinte ich kann das nicht hoch stellen ich kann
das oben hinstellen habe ich es so hingestellt gut da mal ein bisschen geschwätzt so und das
war für mich schon ultra anstrengend da irgendwelche smalltalk sachen zu führen und als ich dann
irgendwann gemerkt habe irgendwie das ist dann so dass das drifte da so ein bisschen ab in ja was
was so was macht man denn hier so und so hatte ich schon wieder überhaupt kein bock drauf es ist für
mich ich kann das unten ich kann ich kann das schlecht beschreiben für mich ist unglaublich
anstrengend so so beziehung aufzubauen zu leuten und selbst sollte es nur so unverfänglich anfangen
wie small talk im zug das das ist das ist für mich schon schon belastend ja
und
ja vielleicht ein bisschen ich mein es ist insofern schon mal ganz cool zu wissen dass
ich die strecke zum bahnhof wieder rennen kann ohne danach zu verrecken
wenn ich richtig erinnere benutzt ja vor immer da wollte ich fragen wieso du nicht
kuemo benutzt nur wegen auffahrer hast du kuemo schon mal unter windows benutzt mal ganz davon
abgesehen kuemo alleine bringt ja nichts du brauchst ja irgendeinen back-end noch dazu und ich würde
mal sagen das geht unter windows schlicht nicht gescheit zumindest nicht auf dem niveau wie
vor immer workstation das kann der grund ist dass vor immer workstation einfach gut funktioniert
ne ne ne darkseid du hast mich falsch verstanden das letzte was ich machen will ist auch noch deep
talk mit den leuten smalltalk reicht mir schon aber ich finde ich finde das mega anstrengend so
so beziehungen aufzubauen zu anderen leuten am besten geht das noch mit anderen technik
begeisterten dann hat man was über das man ein bisschen schwitzen schwitzen kann und vielleicht
stellt man dabei auch dabei auch fest man versteht sich ganz gut ja ich habe es okay ich glaube das
beste beispiel ist doch das was ich euch schon ein paar mal von der weihnachtsfeier erzählt
habe oder ich meine da werde ich schon mal gefragt kannst du mich heimbringen und ich gehe lieber
ich haue lieber ins hotel ab anstatt zu heimzubringen also kommt mein viel planloser
und und unfähiger für zwischenmenschliche sachen kannst du doch eigentlich gar nicht mehr sein
o c bull for fun dankeschön für den sub
wie läuft es mittlerweile im neuen job also an sich finde ich wirklich nice also gerade
der umgang mit den leuten dort ist sehr angenehm im vergleich zum alten arbeitgeber was mir
persönlich ein bisschen auf den kicks geht ist dass alles sehr restriktiv ist und sehr langsam
geht aber da muss ich mich dran gewöhnen weil letztendlich kriege ich das geld ob ich schnell
bin oder langsam bin und wenn es nicht an mir liegt tja was soll ich machen das winners notebook ist
immer noch winners notebook dating apps wie gesagt ich habe überhaupt keinen bock das ist ja das
problem sobald sich abzeichnet dass ich da zwischenmenschlich irgendwas ergeben könnte
ist das so ist das so stressig für mich immer beziehungsweise was heißt stressig
stressig und gleichermaßen so des des interesse daran das weiter zu verfolgen es ist schwierig ich
ich glaube ich bin nicht geeignet für zwischenmenschliche sachen sondern ich gut
ich weiß warum mache ich denn den ganzen tag was am computer und mit technik sachen
dass ich mich nicht so viel mit leuten aus einer setzen muss ja
linux user group würde ich sagen oder? frag wikipedia
wäre bestimmt anders wenn die frau linux kram machen würde
ja genau das das ist glaube ich die beste beste beschreibung da habe ich
kein bock drauf naja gut so sieht es halt aus
ok irgendjemand hat gesagt max such doch noch mal nach servatmen
warum datest du nicht eine aus dem c++ gremium also die einzigen hast du mal angeguckt wie die
alle ausschauen ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr flamen ja aber die einzige die ich kenne aus
dem c++ gremium ist so eine keine ahnung 60 jährige oma mit grauen haren von der habe ich
ein paar vorträge gesehen ich glaube nicht dass man leute aus dem c++ gremium daten will was
auch viel schlimmer ist was auch viel schlimmer ist wahrscheinlich musst du mit denen auch noch
über c++ reden ey leute jeder jeder worauf man bock hat wenn einer eine runde gachi bass machen
will haut rein und ist ein bisschen hell hier so irgendwie mein doch ich soll nach server
admin suchen oder guck mal mal hier was haben wir denn hier zu bieten
gibt es auch server leute nach was soll ich suchen server administrator oder system administrator
keine ahnung ob es da auf der arbeit welche gibt ja bestimmt
aber
wie sagt man so schön never fuck the company weiß ich ob das so eine gute idee ist
sondern was sag mal server admin oder system administrator wo finden wir besser was
sucht nach it allrounder für mittelständische unternehmen da werde ich nichts finden
system server ok system admin ist ok gibt zwar wieder nix dann suchen wir hier bei
system administrator in unix sap sql
darf man links pausen ja klar wenn du eine gute anzeige hast schieß los system administrator
hier gehts los komisch dass du so probleme hast in small to work fuck
wollte ich gar nicht anklicken ok das ist das ist irgendwie anzeige oder
ich kann auch real life also das muss man unterscheiden ob ich rede oder ob ich mit
leuten reden muss das ist ja das ist ja ein großer das ist ja ein großer
unterschied ich höre ich höre mich selber gerne reden ohne frage sonst
würde ich nicht youtube und twitch machen und hier kann ich ja auch mir
überlegen über was ich rede ich meine ich kann random irgendwelchen shit
erzählen zweieinhalb drei stunden lang und ich muss jetzt nicht überlegen so
nach dem motto wie kam das denn jetzt bei dem anderen an und musste den auch mal
zu wort kommen lassen oder die und was sagst denn jetzt darauf und ja wie
tust du denn jetzt so als würde dich das interessieren was die erzählen das
gibt es halt hier nicht deswegen ist das hier überhaupt gar kein
problem ich kann auch ohne probleme irgendwelche
präsentationen oder andere sachen halten das juckt mich überhaupt nicht
ich mache das mittlerweile sogar gerne weil ich irgendwie sogar mittlerweile
für mich entdeckt habe dass ich das cool finde wenn ich vorne stehe und
quasi alle mir zugucken müssen aber es ist ein unterschied ob du quasi die
ansprache machst oder ob du mit jemand reden musst
ok was haben wir denn hier beidwerk eier legen wollen mich sau mwd ist das eine
fake anzeige oder suchen die wirklich was
du bist technischer allrounder kannst alles und hast wenig erwartung an ein
abend das ist das ist doch das ist doch verarschung oder oder es ist jebait um
danach zu sagen ach übrigens wir suchen doch leute
boulder feste anstellung ab sofort vollzeit
jetzt erinnert mich ein bisschen leute leute kennt ihr noch die beste die beste
anzeige für einen linux engineer hey wir suchen einen verdammt genialen senior
linux engineer der windows als das scheißsystem betrachtet dass es ist
das ist immer noch die beste das immer die beste stellenanzeige die wir uns
generiert haben der windows als das scheißsystem betrachtet dass es ist wenn
du ein linux guru bist der jeden befehl wie ein boss beherrscht dann bist du
bei uns richtig du solltest die cloud wie deine rückseite eine handkerl zeugs wie
kubanetis und neuskill besser beherrschen als deine eigene muttersprache
der es liebt agil zu sein und der sec bis finn ob's in den griff zu bekommen
das ist doch mal was so ne anzeige da würde ich mich sofort drauf bewerben
moment ich sollte es zu ende lesen sekunde ich auch fack wo ist der chat also was wir bieten
einfach so jetzt geht's weiter ok jetzt ja war klar dass da noch irgendwas was das da noch
irgendwas kommt ja ja das ist eine anzeige die habe ich über chat gpt generiert ich hab
wir mussten chat gpt erstmal sagen schimpfwörter sind ok und dann konnten wir sagen so nach dem
motto wir suchen in linux ab mit der wir noch scheiße finden schreibt man eine stellenanzeige
ok jetzt wenn du dir alles durchgelesen auf unsere normal bei mercedes ich glaube dort
ist wirklich nicht schlecht habe ich schon von paar gehört das richtig nice sein soll
bei mercedes zu arbeiten aber wohl auch sehr restriktiv
du baust und deliverst in mercedes-benz rechenzentrum und eschow und aller klar
gar nicht schlecht geschrieben die anzeige
klingt gar nicht so schlecht
AxiCorp, was wollen die?
Wir verkaufen EU-Arzheimittel.
Was wollen die haben?
Die suchen einen Systemadministrator.
Männlich weiß deutsch für?
Gibt es nicht viele Infos zu?
Sicherstellung der Funktionsfähigkeit der IT-Systems, ok das ist äußerst allgemein
gehalten.
Umsetzung neuer Sicherheitskonzepte, Weiterentwicklung der Netzwerke und IT-Strukturen, Server und
Client-Virtualisierung, First und Second Levels, ok, da bin ich raus, da bin ich raus, ich
meine, wie gesagt, ich sowiehe keinen Job, aber da wäre ich raus, First Level Support,
MonkaS, Alter, hör mal bloß auf, ich meine, ich kann auch schlecht alles das hier machen
und dann auch First Level Support, das ist auch wieder einer, der alles macht, oder?
Übrigens, hier steht, hier steht nicht eine Sache drin, was die eigentlich wollen, also
was die eigentlich, eigentlich machen, genau, beziehungsweise mit was für Technologien
und sonst was, da steht ja gar nichts. Magst du mal auf die Anzeige gucken? Ja, klar. Akzeptieren,
auf geht's. Okay, Chat, wir machen wieder eine Runde Stellenanzeigen Consulting. Also was
haben wir denn hier? Mein erstes Problem, ich hätte keine Ahnung, wie man euch schreibt,
wie man euch ausspricht. Also da hätte ich wirklich sehr großen Interpretationsspielraum,
wie man die Sache ausspricht. Aber gut, ist ja dafür auch nicht wirklich wichtig. Cool finde
ich schon mal, dass da Remote am Start ist. Remote Vollzeit. Okay.
Wir setzen uns so was wie Messe oder sowas.
Zwuff? Zwuff? Okay, da wäre ich im Leben nicht drauf gekommen, dass man das Zwuff spricht.
So bieten wir spannende Perspektiven für rund 350 Mitarbeiter in Deutschland,
in Deutschland, der Schweiz und den Niederlanden.
Du bist auf der Suche nach einem abwechslungsreichen, interessanten Aufgabenwettbewerb.
Full-Stack-Developer.
Entwicklung, Optimierung, Betreuung browserbasierter Applikationen vorwiegend in der Cloud.
Klingt vollkommen okay dafür.
Erstellung intuitiver Benutzeroberflächen und Einführung neuer Features von der Konzeption
bis zur Programmierung.
Sicherstellung der reibungslosen Kommunikation zwischen dem Frontend und dem Backend durch
fortschrittliche Service-Entwicklung, Verbindung externer Systeme in die Software-Integra-Sociale,
kontinuierliche Verbesserung der Software-Architektur für neue Technologien, Unterstützung bei
der Federdiagnose und Behebung und Entwicklung automatisierten Tests, enge Zusammenarbeit
mit anderen Business-Units, Ansprechpartner für das Entwicklungsteam, das Produktmein und weite.
Ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel des Guten, oder? Ich meine, dass man mal gefragt wird nach seiner
Expertise, ist ja vollkommen normal, aber wenn es hier so drinnen steht, würde ich vermuten,
dass das auch zu meinen, wie soll ich sagen, zu meinen regelmäßigen Aufgaben gehört,
zu meinen Pflichtaufgaben gehört. Oder weiß ich nicht, ob ich da Bock drauf hätte.
Wenn mich ab und zu mal mein Chef fragt nach meiner Expertise, ist das ja vollkommen normal,
aber so als Standardansprechpartner für alle fungieren. Gut, ich meine, kann man ja reinschreiben,
die Frage, was man haben will. Praktische Erfahrungen in der Entwicklung von Web-Anwendungen,
Datenbanken, verteiltes System, HTML, CSS, TypeScript, JavaScript, Angular und Node.js,
gute Erfahrungen mit C-Sharp.net. Ah, sehr gute Sache. Sehr gute Sache. Genau das Richtige für
mich. Nur, dass ich keinen Job suche. Wenigstens war einer, der heute, heute hatten wir nur Java
Stellen anzeigen. Kenntnisse, Webster, Fähigkeiten, sich schnell. Ja, okay, das ist wichtig. Gute
Erfahrungen im Bereich der Implementierung von Softwarearchitekturen. Hohe Affinität zu moderner
Software. Scrum-Arbeit in Agile Entwicklern ist seine Vorteile bei Swoof. Alle Swoover profitieren
von überdurchschnittlichen Sozialleistungen, nehmen neuen attraktiven Bürostande und mobiles
Arbeiten möglich. 30 Tage Urlaub, kostenfreie Snacks. Wir sind...
Wie viele Leute haben da wirklich Hunde dabei? Wir sind fit, da ist Fitnessraum.
Okay, an sich nicht irgendwie groß übertrieben, aber ja gut, warum findet man da niemand? Also
eine Sache, die ich vielleicht sagen könnte, eine Sache, die ich vielleicht sagen könnte,
wenn ihr Vorteile habt, so in Richtung, sagen wir mal, freie Betriebssystemauswahl, ein Smartphone,
was man vom Arbeitgeber bekommt, auch privat benutzen darf, höhenverstellbare Schreibtische,
Kantine im Haus und solche Sachen, schreibt das ruhig rein, weil das wäre für mich persönlich
jetzt ausschlaggebender als, dass es kostenfreie Snacks und Getränke gibt oder dass man Hunde mit
nehmen darf. Also je nachdem, wenn es da was gibt, was euch vielleicht ganz selbstverständlich
erscheint, kann das durchaus ein cooler Vorteil sein für jemanden, der sich neu bewirbt und nicht
weiß, dass es das gibt. Ansonsten, ja, ich würde sagen, ihr sucht halt jemand, der hauptsächlich
Frontendentwicklung macht, der allerdings auch ein bisschen Plan hat, was beckern angeht. Ja,
und hier wäre ich nicht so richtig schlaut draus, aber ansonsten sieht die Stellenanzeige ganz okay
aus, ja. Ich würde jetzt allerdings auch nicht sagen, dass die super innovativ irgendwie
heraussticht zwischen all den anderen. Die ist aber weit davon entfernt, mies zu sein, ja. Also
wir hatten schon ganz andere Kaliber hier. Das ist vollkommen okay, die Stellenanzeige,
vielleicht in der heutigen Zeit ein bisschen zu normal. Ich weiß nicht, scheint sich ja keiner
darauf zu bewerben. Also ich kann es dir nicht sagen, woran es liegt, ehrlich gesagt. Zu
viel Text. Ja, eher da stimmt ein bisschen viel Text. Es ist schwer zu sagen. Ja.
Tatsächlich suchen wir eher einen DevOps-Kerl, weil wir als Entwickler mittlerweile
dann sucht doch mal explizit nach irgendeine mit DevOps-Erfahrung, weil aktuell sucht ihr
tatsächlich einen Programmierer, das ist aber ein Software-Entwickler. Also für mich liest
sich die Stellanzeige, okay das wäre vielleicht echt ein Problem, da hätten wir vielleicht wirklich
schon ein Problem festgestellt. Also ich meine für mich liest sich die Stellanzeige tatsächlich,
können wir gleich machen, liest sich die Stellanzeige als sucht ihr hauptsächlich einen
Frontend-Entwickler, der ein bisschen Backend-Zeug Ahnung hat, gerade im .NET Umfeld und vielleicht
auch mal ganz gerne so ein bisschen seine Expertise im Unternehmen verteilt, so vielleicht mal die ein
oder andere Präsentation hält und Ansprechpartner für die Chefs ist. Also das liest man tatsächlich,
finde ich relativ schlecht aus der Anzeige raus, dass ihr einen DevOps-Kerl sucht. Ja,
das ist leider, leider ist das so. Die meisten Stellenanzeigen beginnen immer mit. Wir sind
das geilste Unternehmen aller Zeiten und der Marktführer im Bereich XY. Ganz ehrlich,
jetzt mal ernsthaft Leute, wenn ihr euch irgendwo beworben habt, habt ihr euch darauf beworben,
weil im ersten Satz stand, wir sind Marktführer im Bereich XY. Das geht mir doch so was von
am Arsch vorbei. So, das sollte ich mir angucken und noch das da. Das hier auch noch. Okay,
ich akzeptiere das mal. Senior Linux Support Engineer, das ist eine Kombination, die habe
ich auch noch nicht gesehen. Ein Senior Linux Support Engineer, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Ich muss das mal kurz rüber kopieren, mir ist die Seite zu hell.
Okay, Senior Linux Support Engineer, Vollzeit oder Teilzahl ab 32 Stunden,
hätte sich ja fast für mich geeignet. Wie gesagt, ich suche ja keine Stelle,
ich hab ja eine Seite, 1. April. Niemand ist perfekt und nicht alle Karrierewege sind grad
ledig, bewirb dich jetzt, auch wenn du nicht. Das finde ich schon mal gut geschrieben. Nicht
so dieses, wir sind die geilsten auf dieser Welt und feiern uns übelst ab,
weil wir Marktführer im Bereich XY sind. Das finde ich auch tatsächlich mal ganz gut,
das reinzuschreiben, weil die meisten sehen das ja auch so. Für die meisten Stellenanzeigen,
also die meisten Recruiter sind ja schon happy, wenn die Leute ein paar Punkte erfüllen. Ich
finde es aber nicht schlecht, das tatsächlich explizit mal reinzuschreiben, weil ich sehe ja
beide Seiten hier im Stream. Wir haben auch oft genug Leute im Chat, die fragen, kann ich mich da
bewerben, auch wenn ich irgendwie zwei Punkte oder so nicht erfülle? Ja klar, warum nicht? Wie gesagt,
die meisten freuen sich, wenn man schon ein paar Punkte erfüllt. Also den ersten Satz finde ich
schon mal gut. Entgegennehmen und qualifizieren von eingehenden Problembeschreibungen und fragen
rund um den Einsatz unserer Linux basierten Produkte. Okay, klingt nach Endkunden, Telefonen,
Kram. Würde sich mein Bock jetzt schon in Grenzen halten, aber gut, ich meine,
es steht in der Überschrift, ja. Nur weil ich darauf keinen Bock habe, heißt es ja nicht,
dass du schlecht bist. Lösen der teils anspruchvollen technischen, ach so, hä? Moment,
was macht man da? Du bist, okay, also man wird quasi angerufen von Leuten, die Produkte dort
gekauft haben und muss dann Support leisten quasi. Die sagen dann, hey, wir haben Probleme beim
Verbinden von unserem gekauften Produkt zu Service XY und dann muss man mit denen irgendwie gucken,
dass man eine Lösung findet. So würde ich das jetzt verstehen. Analyse der technischen Probleme
auf den Kundensystem und euch nachstellen holen. Ja, okay, das ist Support für Leute. Die Produkte,
was machen die denn hier? Univention AppSend. Davon habe ich sogar schon mal was gehört. Das
kommt mir sogar bekannt vor. Das habe ich schon mal irgendwo. Das habe ich schon mal gehört irgendwo.
Ich kann es jetzt nicht genau fest nageln, aber das habe ich irgendwo schon mal gehört.
Univention, UCS. Was waren die denn? Demo?
O-Cloud? Nextcloud? What?
Okay, jetzt weiß ich nicht wirklich, was es sein sollte, aber okay. Geht ja auch um die
Stellenanzeige. Kommunikation mit unseren Kunden, Ausbau und Pflege der Wissenstaatenbank als Mitglied
unseres Supportteams für zufriedene Kunden sorgen. Hätte ich persönlich gar keinen Bock
drauf, weil ich auf Endkundensupport nur wirklich überhaupt keinen Bock hab, aber wie gesagt,
nur weil ich da keinen Bock drauf hab, heißt das ja noch lange nix. Dein Knowhow, mindestens
drei Jahre Berufserfahrung im Bereich der Lienungssystemadministration und Support,
vollkommen gerechtfertigt. Ihr sucht ja eine Senior oder zumindest mit Möglichkeit zur Senior
Stelle. Ihr könntet, wenn ihr wirklich eine Senior Stelle sucht, durchaus, mein drei Jahre
ist sehr human noch. Ihr könntet auch fünf Jahre schreiben, aber nachdem man eh keine Leute
findet, schreibt ruhig drei Jahre. Spaß am Umgang mit Kunden. Okay, da hört es bei mir
schon mal auf. Ich wäre da nicht der Richtige für. Flexible Arbeitszeiten.
Wir haben keine Kernarbeitszeiten. Standard, du entscheidest, ob das, das finde ich schon
mal gut. Windows, obwohl wir geben dir die, oh Pluspunkt, Leute. Riesen Pluspunkt. Freie
Betriebssystem Auswahl. Ja Max, ich guck gleich. Freie Betriebssystem Auswahl. Sehr großer
Pluspunkt. Also wäre es für mich zumindest. Und ich kann nur allen Unternehmen empfehlen,
die das haben, es auch reinzuschreiben. Ja, du kannst auch Arch Linux verwenden.
Wir geben dir die Wahl, mit welchem Betriebssystem du arbeiten möchtest.
Finde ich gut. Wenn ihr jetzt noch ordentlich bezahlt, finde ich das wirklich eine gute
Stellenanzeige, beziehungsweise was, worauf man sich bewerben könnte, wenn man Bock auf
Kundenkontakt hat. Ja, also für mich wäre es nix. Aber ja, ja, finde ich nicht schlecht.
Nicht schlecht. Hast du eigentlich einen Steam Deck?
Nee, hab ich nicht. Okay, und das soll ich mir auch noch angucken. Zeig mal her.
Gehört zu den weltweit führenden Dienstleistern. Alter, die Einleitungssätze sind immer echt so
langweilig. Blabla. Wir bauen unsere Lieferfähigkeit im Umfeld Cybersecurity mit dem...
Wie Business-BWL-Stonks-Mensch-mäßig möchtest du einen Satz schreiben?
Ihr kommt vielleicht auch irgendwann nochmal, was sie suchen. Homeoffice-Möglichkeit sowie
Vereinbarung mit Vergütungszuschluss. Remoteworks sowie mobiles Arbeiten im EU-Ausland kumuliert
bis zu 120 Tage im Kalenderjahr ermöglicht. 120 Tage im Kalenderjahr ermöglicht. Heißt im
Prinzip ich muss 50 Prozent derzeit im Büro anwesend sein oder oder mehr noch mehr oder
bezieht sich das jetzt nur aufs Ausland. Ach aus steuerlichen Gründen. Ah verstehe verstehe
okay. Ach verstehe okay dann ergibt das Sinn ja. Doktor Pro Noob schick schick mal was.
Interne.
Du konzeptierst und implementierst eigenständig und gemeinsam mit unseren robusten public
und hybrid cloud architekturen roadmaps. Du steuerst aktiv und koordinierst unser
projekt und führst international aufgestellte project teams für namhafte kunden aus.
du hast bereits mehrjährige ausgeprägte kunde du verfügst über beratung beratung so viel
beratung was sucht ihr noch mal ok ihr sucht ein senior architekt cloud security ok das ist
super krasse kombination aus alle möglichen ja ok ok liest sich zwar nicht so richtig
dann cloud architekt aber ja gut man ja es ist in beratungsladen
zertifikate und weiter mit cloud architekt muss das wirklich sein ok
wahrscheinlich kann man dann die leute besser verkaufen oder besser besser
sagen wir haben super kompetente leute
ich kann dir dazu jetzt wirklich nicht viel sagen weil für mich wäre es
überhaupt gar nichts weil
ja so entkunden kontakt und sowas super spannend geschrieben ist sie auch nicht
also
alter chrome schock mich
und ks könnt ihr ein linux für linux anfänger empfehlen ja als erstes mal inner4m
als erstes mal linux inner4m ausprobieren und dann ja linux mint würde ich auch sagen korrekt
ein nicht arsch linux mint sage ich auch öfters wallpaper als der pippo schläft war mal kurz
ein update wenn ich gerade die vm an hab also am besten am besten tatsächlich linux
erste mal in der vm neben windows dass du dir das angucken kannst in ruhe und halt auch
zurück kannst und schnell um switchen kann was denn jetzt los usb imager ist brokener dann
wird es wieder deinstalliert easy zack boom doch weg ist es ob und wo 1304 ist raus tatsächlich
nein wir sollten uns tatsächlich das mal angucken in einem der nächsten streams was sie da ob sie
wieder neuen snapshot eingebaut haben und sowas wsl ist kein vollständiger vm ersatz
aber wsl ist wer sonst keine möglichkeit hat immer noch die bessere bessere alternative
statt gar kein linux kram hyper wie keine praktischen erfahrungen damit
ja nö da gibt es da gibt es halt nix haben sie halt pech so ein bisschen um was es geht
müssen die schon erzählen sonst wäre mir auch die zeit zu schade 12 minuten luna lobster ja
dieses ubuntu hat tatsächlich mal wieder einen sinnvollen oder den coolen projekt
ne wie heißt das bei denen so so so release name ja für einsteiger schon und ich würde dir auch
zur wie heißt das was die standardmäßig für den desktop haben cinnamon was hat was hat mint
mate oder cinnamon ja er kann alle drei nehmen kannst alle drei nehmen alle drei alle drei ok
musst aber gucken was dir besser was dir besser gefällt ja mate ist mate und xfc sind ein bisschen
old school ich persönlich finde sie aber ganz angenehm und cinnamon ist so ein bisschen die
alternative wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich auch der der bessere von den desktops wo die meiste
arbeit reinfließt das ist nur die optische oberfläche das ist richtig aber das ist das
womit ein anfänger hauptsächlich in kontakt kommt kann man wsl wieder anständig entfernen
wsl 2 ist ja eine vm kannst das reinstallen ja das geht aber frag mich bitte nicht wie
edv forensik poggers subscription dankeschön nice
eben hatten wir genau die richtige stellenanzeige für dich wir hatten einen cloud cloud security
senior architekt oder sowas klingt auch genau richtig
ich verstehe nicht so ganz was ein beginner linux ist ich kann jetzt zum beispiel ein beispiel
nennen was definitiv kein beginner linux ist zum beispiel gente oder oder gentoo wie das manche
aussprechen was macht eine was macht eine distribution zu einer beginner distribution
naja das offensichtlichste was eine distribution zu einer beginner distribution macht ist wenn das
ding out of the box mit einer auch für ehemaligen winos benutzer verständlich in oberfläche kommt
und ich nicht erschlägt mit 1000 programm sondern eben sinnvolle vorinstallation hat
alles soweit eingerichtet dass wenn du was download ist dass du es auch anklicken kannst
im download fenster es öffnet sich das richtige programm dass es sich über den ui installieren
lässt zum beispiel ja also gibt schon ein paar kriterien natürlich gibt es sehr viele
distributionen die sich die das mehr oder weniger haben und sich auch als einsteiger
distribution eignen würden aber ich persönlich finde distributionen mit
dem gewissen verbreitungsfaktor immer nicht verkehrt weil zum beispiel sowas wie mint oder
ubuntu findest du halt sehr viel dazu ja im artschwecki findest du auch viel zu artschwecks da
musst du den kram erst mal installiert bekommen was mit dem margin store eigentlich auch relativ
easy ist mittlerweile aber für anfänger ist es trotzdem nichts und gerade wenn du nach hilfe
suchst ist halt linux mint oder ubuntu super geschichte ja genau und dann am besten in
der vm und sich wundert warum es nicht funktioniert wir sollen uns echt mal wieder linux mint angucken
haben wir schon eine weile nicht mehr oder ich weiß gar nicht wie die aktuellen releases so
sind basierend auf sind die mittlerweile auf debian based oder
hast du schon mal no bara angeguckt nee sagt mir nix no bara linux
fedora oder freitag basierte sachen habe ich kein bock
da gibt es für mich nur zwei sachen die in frage kommen abt oder direkt arch
beispielsweise packman also debian based oder arch based das andere hätte ich auch
im desktop kein bock nicht mal auf gentu aber kollege von ex-kollege von mir hat gentu
meine ganze zeit lang verwende war ich ja gentu fan und ich weiß noch als der sein notebook neu
hatte ich stimmt gar nicht nicht sein notebook dass der als er sich den linox vm eingerichtet
hat musste irgendwie dreimal körner neu kompilieren bis er den vmw netzwerk treiber
drinne hatte und das sind so dinger das ist für ein tägliches arbeitsbetriebssystem ja nix
was hältst du von so open suse abstand nicht so falsch falscher komm abstand also um suse
basierte sag generell um suse mache ich einen riesen bogen und habe auch nicht vor sie zu
benutzen also suse no pass muss echt nicht sein
nicht benutzt
um keinen sus weil ich es nicht mag ich mag das ganze handling nicht ich mag ja
rpm basierte sachen schon nicht wirklich und dann es kommt zu sie noch mal mit
zipper und und jast und orne sus ist nicht nicht meins die bundeswehr mag
susi ja gut was die bundeswehr mag muss jetzt nicht unbedingt so das beste sei
die bundeswehr mag auch 30 jahre alte flugzeuge und sachen die nicht mal fahren
oder segelschefe die irgendwie seit langem renoviert werden
das tatsächlich ich hatte auch als aller aller allererstes kontakt mit susi ich
habe damals susi sogar gekauft noch auf cds wo susi noch so blaue blaue cds hatte
aber das war auch mein erster kontakt mit linux und der war
nicht sonderlich lang und auch nicht sonderlich von viel erfolg gekrönt
was findest du an mint besser als ubuntu ich könnte dir das aktuell noch nicht mal sagen
weil ich beides schon lange auf dem desktop nicht mehr groß ausführlich benutzt habe
tatsächlich ubuntu ubuntu hatte ich als arbeits vm vor noch nicht allzu langer zeit
aber intensiv benutzt habe ich auch nicht zumindest mag ich den standard desktop von
ubuntu nicht ist ja mittlerweile genau based aber auch usability mäßig echt nicht mein fall wenn
auch besser als standart gnome standart gnome ist ja komplette komplette zumutung mittlerweile
ja ansonsten kann ich das gar nicht genau sagen ich habe beide schon eine weile nicht
ubuntu cinnamon wäre was für dich warum nicht einfach mint cinnamon nee ich glaube nicht dass
es was für mich wäre weil ich persönlich keine klassischen desktops mag was ja auch der grund
ist warum ich eigentlich nur i3 benutze weil i3 ist halt einfach vorhanden ist halt einfach da
und nervt mich und alles andere nervt mich unter linux deswegen benutze ich halt i3 weil
weil es einfach nicht in die quere kommt habe ich jetzt eigentlich update gemacht
deswegen wie gesagt deswegen habe ich die drei weil es nicht nervt
und außerdem ascii aquarium beste ne xfce ist auch ganz ok
also meine desktop die ich die letzten jahre über hatte lasst mal überlegen
ich hatte ubuntu ganz am anfang das war ja noch gnome 2
dann hatte ich mal kurz e17 zum paar paar wochen weiß ich noch war müll dann hatte ich ganz lange
fluxbox openbox oder fluxbox eins von beiden und jetzt die letzten jahre und schon lange jahre
eigentlich ausschließlich i3 also so mit klassischen desktops kann ich unter linux einfach
nichts anfangen kann kann wer was zu poppo es sagen ja ich glaube wir hatten poppo es hier
im stream sogar mal ausprobiert und das hat mir nicht gut gefallen
kann man ascii aquarium als lockscreen nutzen? glaube nicht
das stimmt aber auf dem desktop dürfte wahrscheinlich mint wenn man community
mäßig hilfe braucht fast noch besser sein
ja aber kali selbst ist ja nicht als standard linux desktop fürs tägliche benutzen gedacht
das stimmt ist kali nicht sogar xfc ne lxd oder so was kali hat auch so was ganz merkwürdiges
keine ahnung was ist deine lieblingsdestro beziehungsweise meist benutzt dazu kann ich
nur sagen arch by the way das was ich zu 95 prozent benutze genau diese kombination die
hier die du hier siehst arch linux westerm als terminal i3 als window manager fertig
aktuellen gnome desktop kann ich mir nicht geben warum feiern viele arch
weil du es dir komplett so einrichten kannst wie du willst weil es ursprünglich halt sehr
minimalistisch ist und darauf aufbauen kannst weil du eine riesen paket auswahl hast und den wie
ich finde angenehmsten und besten package manager von allen linux distributionen vor allem der
schnellste und insofern ist arch halt beliebt by the way hyperland ja habe ich habe ich ausprobiert
läuft in der vm nicht war nicht zum laufen zu bringen in der vm dementsprechend habe ich
sein lassen mein anwendungszweck ist halt ich brauche linux in der vm warum näher weil ich
linux halt auf dem zweiten desktop laufen habe wie ihr seht ich mache alles in unter linux was
technik sachen sind und den rest mache ich unter windows also insofern ich brauche halt beides und
da ist ein window manager der nur auf echte hardware läuft halt nicht brauchbar deswegen
gar nicht zu hyperland auch nicht sagen stream die ctfs machen linux hacker mäßig haben wir
haben doch schon haben wir haben doch letzten schon so was gemacht in der richtung halt linux
fokussiert jetzt weniger weniger sicherheitslücken mäßig sondern linux probleme fixen gibt es da
eigentlich was neues lass mal kurz gucken oh guck mal es gibt neue sachen naja neue sachen
ist ein bisschen zu viel oder ich mein guck mal hatten wir das schon gemacht
das haben wir schon gemacht ja ich glaube da gibt es wirklich bloß hier den neuen
sonst ansonsten nix hier ist was dazu gekommen guck mal medium
das ist neu das kenne ich noch nicht kihei immer das ist neu das kenne ich noch nicht
aber das hier also die zwei sachen sind neu die haben wir noch nicht gemacht das könnten wir
tatsächlich demnächst und ich glaube dass kuba näht das ding haben wir auch noch nie gemacht
haben wir auch noch nicht gemacht also die drei sachen können wir tatsächlich demnächst mal
wieder machen ich schreibe es mir mal auf
du sprichst kuba näht das interessant aus ja ich sprich dir das ja sprich dir
irgendwie ein bisschen anders aus am schlimmsten finde ich kuba näht es
oh leute ich gucke gerade auf die uhr wisst ihr was jetzt ist
was ist jetzt boomer müde
24 wäre echt notwendig fast schon boomer müde boomer schlafen
morgen stream durchaus möglich weiß ich noch nicht genau ich habe ja keine regelmäßige
stream schedule das ist halt so das ding das ist auch was wo ich mir sicher bin das würde euch
wahrscheinlich gefallen und das würde auch generell noch noch mehr leute noch mehr regelmäßige viewer
bringen wenn ich ne stream schedule hätte aber habe ich keinen bock drauf ich krieg das einfach
nicht gescheit geplant montag ist schon recht regelmäßig ja aber die urzeit ist random und
könnte man könnte es tatsächlich besser machen aber ich krieg das krieg das nicht gescheit
geplant und es ist ja ich meine es würde insofern helfen es ist ja eh schon äußerste
nischen mäßig hier auf twitch ja ich kann mich eigentlich wirklich glücklich schätzen dass dass
ich so viele zuschauer auf twitch haben wird das was wir hier machen ich meine wir machen google
cloud kubernetes zeug wir basteln ihre javascript frontend sachen es gibt wenige streams die so
was machen und so viele zuschauer haben also kann ich eigentlich wirklich sehr zufrieden sein außerdem
habe ich den intelligentesten chat auf twitch hätten die chat gpt erfinder gewusst dass es
den wubblos chat gibt da hätten sich chat gpt erfinden gleich sparen können
ich brauche wohl demnächst eine fritzbox gibt es da eine brauchbare alternative also wenn
du wirklich eine fritzbox brauchst dann gibt es dazu keine gute alternative
weil fritzboxen so ziemlich konkurrenzlos sind was so das gesamtpaket angeht gerade wenn du
eine deckbasis station noch brauchst und die ganzen sachen die da drin sehen die fritzbox ist
halt ein ziemlich gutes fast schon konkurrenzloses so multifunktionsgerät wenn du einen router
brauchst und es dir um routing funktionen geht dann ist eine fritzbox nix absolut linux
kenne ich nicht hört sich an wie irgendwie was russisches oder so so absolut wort gar
er würde ich sagen da müssen wir dich das nächste mal hosten dann gucken wir ein paar
mehr zu weil ich halt auch denke dass das wahrscheinlich noch nischenmäßiger ist
und dementsprechend noch schwieriger ist leute da zu begeistern von
ob noch open wrt auf fritz box läuft ich glaube nicht es gibt so einen es gibt so
einen vergessen wie das heißt es gibt eben so eine custom fritz firma weiß ich nicht ob
sie noch ob die noch läuft aber nicht ist es glaube ich nicht open wrt da steht übrigens
auch noch anders habe ich noch ganz vergessen
unify haben wir die hier drinnen stehen ja open wrd flaschen auf meine unify access points
ach so du du du du willst du hast die ausfall zwischen fritz box und fritz box ja gut da
musste dir den vergleich auf den ihrer seite angucken das weiß ich aus dem kopf jetzt auch
nicht ich dachte du meinst jetzt fritz box oder was ganz anderes
echt das gibt eine kategorie für so hacker mann sachen auf twitch ich
kenne nur science and technology programming wusste nicht dass es eine für security zeug gibt
alles klar leute ich geh jetzt ins bett bis morgen macht's gut zu